e
e e
good morning today is Thursday January
30th 2025 this is the New Hampshire
House of Representatives Municipal and
County government committee I am
representative Diane power the committee
has convened today for the purpose of of
hearing um public hearing
followed by an executive session this
afternoon now please make sure that your
cell phones are silenced and please join
me in reciting the Pledge of Allegiance
led by representative
grund to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for which
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank
you so before we begin today I have a
few morning
announcements so as I said that the
committee has convened today at 9:30 for
the purpose of public hearings on seven
bills after the public hearing schedule
for
11:10 we the committee hopes to break
for lunch
then public hearings will resume at 100
p.m. and then following at approximately
2 p.m. or thereafter the committee will
hold executive sessions for the seven
bills that we heard last
week so um at some point during the
hearing the com that committee contact
list is back I'm going to be passing
that around and I would ask that if you
don't want want your name shared with
the rest of the committee simply cross
that out and once that's finalized then
I will be distribu Distributing hard
copies to committee members
only and one final note is you members
will see that there are green folders at
your desk areas the folders contain all
printouts of bills that have been
referred to this committee these are
your bills that you will be be working
with this session so what is different
is the the committee assistant will not
pull the bills and put them aside so at
the beginning of the day before the
hearing it will be each member's
responsibility to pull those bills if
you want and you can take the folder
home and study bills um in your spare
time or you can keep them in your file
cabinet drawer
over here whatever works for
you so that's
that so we have um a lot of bills have
been referred to this committee so we
have um tight schedule therefore in
order to stay on schedule today the
chair will allow for up to 5 minutes for
Bill introductions then follow by a
Q&A also the chair will allow up to
three minutes for each speaker each
person providing inperson public
testimony and additional time for
questions and answers if the speaker
allows we will be keeping time and the
vice chair will indicate that the times
I just specified um when they expire he
will hold up a pink card at which time
hopefully you notice and that would be
an indication to um wrap up your
imperson testimony in a sentence or so
if a speaker has written testimony
please indicate such and distribute that
to the committee by um passing your
printed copies of your testimony to
representative kazinski and we will pass
that along the table additionally if a
speaker has more information that they
want to communicate or share with the
committee and they were not um able to
do so because of the the the the time
constraints then please uh indicate that
let me know and then you will I would
like you to follow up with the committee
um via email in something written and
finally as a reminder to people
providing or speaking
and providing um testimony whether it be
a bill introduction or testimony to
please State for the record your name
who you represent and your position on
the bill support oppose or neutral and
then also you'll notice that there's a
little laminated um checklist just as a
a visual reminder so when the clerk is
ready we will begin our
hearings okay
okay
so uh oh what no we don't need
to yeah yeah there was a question about
attendance we don't need to take
attendance cuz a quorum is not needed
for a hearing so in order to however the
clerk is noting attendance on her uh
sheets for the bill file I just thought
that would speed things
up so at this time I will open the
public hearing on House Bill 272
exempting certain agricultural practices
for municipal noise
regulations uh I don't let me see yep I
do not see the prime sponsor however I
see representative Aaron very good thank
you welcome representative Aaron and
good
morning good morning Madam chair and
good morning members of uh Municipal and
County committee it's uh good to be back
here again um I was not anticipating
introducing this bill this morning but
uh seeing as the prime sponsor is not in
attendance and I am a co-sponsor I'd be
happy to introduce this bill to you um
this bill is uh just making a technical
change to language that was already
passed and uh put into statute uh we
want to support our for our farmers and
the work that they do and the times that
they need to do the work that they do so
uh we are just um proposing to strike
the words quiet hours in uh the current
language and that's pretty much um the
essence of this
legislation and so I hope that you will
support the technical change um and and
allow our Farmers to do the kinds of
work that they need to do at the times
that they need to do
them and with that I guess I can attempt
to take some questions although I do H I
do see um members here who uh uh who are
are also willing and able to take
questions from the committee regarding
this
change are there any questions for
representative
Aaron representative
FR thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question um under this bill if
there are
existing qu why at our ordinances are
they grandfathered or they do they
become null and void I believe they are
not
grandfathered
yep further
questions seeing none thank you
representative appreciate it appreciate
the time and work that this committee
does thank you
next the chair calls Mr Jason
stock welcome to Municipal and County
government thank
you well good morning uh for the record
my name's Jason St I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Timberland
Owners Association and this is my first
time in front of this
committee 2025 and happy to be here um
we support the bill um we believe these
technical changes um we believe it does
add some clarity uh the coming around is
just some information on you know why is
a Timber guy here on an egg bill um in
New Hampshire statute
forestry is is considered agricultural
operations under
234a forestry or lumbering as some folks
used to call it way back when was
considered is is is defined as
agriculture um New Hampshire our our
forestry and our in in Forest management
is a is a big part of our economy um our
association we represent land owners but
we also represent loggers Foresters and
and wood processors
and in New Hampshire we're the second
most forested state in the nation uh 83%
of our state is actually covered with
Forest of which
76% is privately owned um unlike many
western states where it's actually the
reverse you have a lot more public
ownership here in the East we of course
have more private ownership coming
around is some information just
articulating that you don't have to take
my word for it this is from the US
Forest Service uh this is a survey data
they do periodic surveys of of the
forest
condition and and so you'll see that
this information as it comes
around why this is important in in kind
of how this dovetails with with House
Bill 272 is New Hampshire law in many
areas recognizes the importance of
Forestry and Forest management we have
current use assessment we have Timber
tax which is actually called the forest
conservation act that both deal with you
know the taxation of land forest land in
Timber um in the current use and the
preamble to that there's actually
language that talks about the importance
of of open space and and Forestry for
the state and even in Planning and
Zoning RSA 672 colon 1 it states um
under the Declaration of purposes the
the harvesting of Timber often
represents the only income that can be
derived from property without resorting
to development of the property for more
intensive uses and pursuant to RSA 79 A1
the state of New Hampshire has declared
that is in the public interest to
declare excuse me to encourage
preservation of open space by conserving
force and other natural
resources so again this ties into house
bill
272 in that the ability to manage and
harvest get some feedback here the
ability to manage and harvest Timber is
important to maintaining that Forest is
Forest um things like noise ordinances
um because we are a seasonal it is a
seasonal business that is subject to the
whims of Mother Nature and weather there
are instances where you do have to
operate in on you know at times of the
day that may not be 9 to5 and so for
that reason things like noise ordinances
can really create a problem when you're
try particular Al in a month or two when
mud season's approaching us and you're
you're walking with a road agent saying
all right I need to move some Timber out
he's like you can do it but you got to
get you got to before you can drive on
those roads and before they warm up you
need to have your trucks out of there by
you know 6:00 a.m. again that can run
into direct conflict with say a quiet
hours or noise ordinance that says you
can't start operating until
8:00 and so we you know having spoken to
the sponsor of this bill the intent of
it is to is to clarify and not make to
clarify that what we're talking about
here are ordinances noise ordinances not
just quote quiet hour ordinances but
noise ordinances in general um since the
law was passed a year or two ago there
have been several instances where again
it has been exercised where you know hey
you can't you know we want to shut your
job down or you can't operate and we've
been able to exercise this to say look
we have some extenda circumstances here
we've got to get if we're going to get
this wood off the The Landing and take
advantage of cold temperatures to not
tear up the road we do need to run we've
been able to exercise this law so and to
kind of put this into context this isn't
you know Timber harvesting happens
across the state when I looked at
2022 report of cut this is from the
timber tax records there are there are
about 2,300 Timber sales that occur
across the state so this is it's not
just an isolated situation and these
occur in in many many many communities
um the vast majority of the communities
in the state even cities like Manchester
and Nashua do have occasionally they'll
have small forestry projects so again
having given you the context why we
support this we think this technical
change does add some clarity in does
does add some clarity and we would
support this and hope you would find
this ought to pass with that I'll
conclude my my testimony and be happy to
try and answer any
questions thank you Mr stock other
questions representative Colby thank you
madam chair uh is there a point where
forestry
activities end uh and land clearing for
construction or development
begins yet there there is and actually
in 67 RSA
674 they talk the where they talk about
the duties of the planning board there's
actually a distinction that's made
between forestry and when a site plan
review or a subdivision is proposed and
that's kind of the trigger is when that
subdiv when you apply for that
subdivision or you're applying for a
site plan review that's when you start
kind of of drifting into these I'll call
the land clearing Arena versus
forestry um having said that there are
instances where I have a piece of
property I I have a family emergency or
a family situation I mean we all have we
all know of circumstances like this
where oh my goodness I just had a Timber
sale but I now have some major medical
bills what have you and maybe I need to
sell a house slot in which case all
right you did your Timber sale as a
Timber sale now file for your
subdivision and anything henceforth is
subject to the zoning or planning
approval further
questions represent
FR thank you madam
chair um would this bill apply or this
exemption apply to a specific spe ific
agricultural activity or forestry
activity on a specific wood lot or would
it extend to that log truck that's going
through town at 4 in the
morning the way I read the bill is it it
applies to the agricultural operation
you're talking you know this is a piece
of property if you have traffic on a
road whether it's a log truck or an
garbage truck or a fuel delivery truck I
see that as a a separate issue and what
we're talking about here is really kind
of a land use issue as opposed
to what you're kind of getting
at that's my interpretation I'm not a
lawyer I'll preface it thank you for
clarifying your
interpretation does anybody else have a
question
seeing none thank you Mr stock thank you
for your time this morning have a nice
day next the chair calls Mr Robert
Johnson welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Rob Johnson and I represent
the New Hampshire Faro as a federation's
policy director and New Hampshire Faro
as a Federation of New Hampshire's 10
County fer organizations consisting of
just under 2500 member families
supporters and Associated businesses and
and we support House Bill 272 and as was
stated earlier we too see it as really
simply a a clarification of the intent
of legislation that was passed by the
you the legislature in uh two years ago
in 2023 through House Bill
252 and to give you an idea of the types
of things when you're talking about
noise ordinances that are uh that affect
agricultural operations would be like
the the application of of crop
protectants whether it be uh pesticides
or herbicides or even fertilizers where
when you're when you're applying
particularly a pesticide you want you
want no wind uh to to to to to to apply
as you should and and it's also in many
instances you you in early in the
morning you'll have a little bit of a do
so some wetness so the the the the
application is where you want it so that
that's really important and it could be
in the evening as well um also uh Mr
stalk mentioned it with with frozen
ground and and I know I have a a small
uh livestock operation and you want to
get out in your ground uh in the in the
spr of the year when the ground's frozen
you don't want to create ruts and get in
the mud and to do that you really you
when the ground tends to be Frozen when
it's darker just middle of the day it
warms up and you can you you want to
mesh your ground up so if you can get
out there to feed livestock or or run a
tractor around the farm uh if if you can
do that early in the morning when the
ground's frozen or later in the evening
and and that also it also applies to
just the harvesting of crops uh as you
know agriculture is weather dependent
and there are times as a farmer when I
can't do my I can't Harvest and get what
I need to do with with coming weather
and that is as Mr talk mentioned that 9
to5 uh time frame I I I need uh you know
when the when the crop is ready it needs
to come in and if it takes uh you know
uh later uh evenings into into the night
um as well in hot weather uh as far as
haying you often you need to Hay if
you've got some lighting on your
equipment to hay in the in the dark if
you go across other parts of the country
because of the heat I mean you'll see
lights on tractors and they're
harvesting right through the night
that's when they harvest they do not
Harvest during the day because of
because of the the Heat and the the
quality of the the of the crop itself
and just to answer a a a question
regarding the the transportation of of
the product if you look if you look at
RSA 21 colon 34- a that that defines
agriculture of uh farm and farming and
statue in section two of that it it it
defines the words Agriculture and
farming it means all operations or
activities of a farm including and then
it lists them you'll see that and it
it's really the the husbandry of
livestock in the the planting growing
harvesting
cultivating of a crop itself in one form
or another it would not include the you
know the delivery to Market or or or
just just the general Transportation
outside of the the bringing it in from
the field on the on the farming
operation okay I again I we we do
support the Bill's clarification we I
appreciate your uh attention and and
thank
you thank you sir are there questions
for Mr
Johnson seeing none thank you
so that represents the last pink card
that I have so at this time I would ask
is there anyone present who wishes to
speak on this bill who has not yet had
the opportunity to do
so seeing none the the chair now
recognizes
oh blue sheet wa after you do that oh
sorry blue Sheet's right next to me
didn't see it so we're going to pass
this
down as I was saying the chair now
recognizes representative Gilman to
report the blue sheets for House Bill
272 thank you madam chair on the um
Right End blue sheet we have one me one
uh vote
for in support of the bill and one
against and on the online
um registration we have six in support
and one opposed
thank you and with that the public
hearing on House Bill
272 is now closed
so interestingly we are 10 minutes ahead
of schedule so the public hearing on the
next bill House Bill 149 is scheduled to
begin in 10 minutes at
10:10 so we're on hold
old
e
e e
is it the time is now 10:11 and we have
House Bill 149 schedule for
1010 so I will open the public hearing
on House Bill 149 FN relative to Warrant
article approvals at ballot referenda
form of town
meeting and I see the prime sponsor is
here to introduce his bill welcome to
Municipal and County government
representative
sellers good good morning I'm just
trying to see if this is turned up last
time I was here it was actually very low
hopefully this will help oh there
there's actually a volume yeah adjust I
didn't know that test test test test
test thank you anyways yeah it's on the
side uh I'm representing John cers
Grafton district 10 up in Bristol uh
Bridgewater area of New
Hampshire and
um thank you uh committee for listening
to a short testimony on this it's pretty
simple overall I at least I think so
it's it's allowing the voters you could
say The Best of Both Worlds you go in
into a delivera to session or Tom
meeting and you have your bill may be
petitioned or may it even be the uh
presented by the select board School
Board in any case changes are made to
that bill or that warrant outgo excuse
me so what this is going to
allow if the changes where the amendment
was approved to the warrant ticle what
it will allow is the
original warrant out will go
forward to the voters and it will also
allow the
amended warant out of to go forward to
the voters so the voters have the
ultimate say and I think that's what we
all want is is is the voters to have the
ultimate say and that's that's all this
does so if someone amends the B amends
the warrant articles any of them then
both go to the voters to to decide and
of course the one that gets the most
votes wins in the case of a tie the
amended one would
win if that ever
happened um I'll take whatever question
I can and I'm hopefully there'll be some
others speaking as well questions for
representative sers the chair recognizes
representative
Murphy thank you madam chair thank you
representative uh thank you for taking
my
question the concern I have what do you
have two or three different amendments
on a warrant
article thank you representative uh of
course on the warrant article the one
the
actual final amended warrant article is
the one that goes forward does that make
sense
yes further
questions the chair recognizes
representative grund thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question so as two towns have public
hearings they have deliberative sessions
and then they have voting there are
three opportunities for voters to
participate in the process along with
budget committees and all those things
that review The Articles putting the
putting the
two different Warren articles on a
ballot in March when voters participate
in deliberative session do you believe
that could be really confusing what
people show up and vote on and cause
more
confusion uh thank you for the question
and I hope not but putting it on the
ballot in March or may it be May
whatever the date May
Be allows
those those people those voters that are
absentee ballot voters because they're
out of town it gives them the chance to
vote on either the initial warrant
article or the amend
so which is which is really ultimate
everybody gets the vote not everybody is
able to show up for a delative session
or a hearing and that's what we always
see I mean uh in my area for a school
district let's say there's 7,000 voters
approximately 100 to 200 voters show up
at a deliver a session but when it comes
time to vote it's around three you know
around 3,000 3,000 vter is 2500 so it's
a big difference
further
questions the chair recognizes
representative
Walker thank you madam chair I I look at
this I just
[Music]
figure having both of them on there
could pose a great deal
of for people not really paying
attention much they see the first one
then they see the second one again they
think it's a redundant or confu a lot of
confusion with this and plus your
statement a while ago you mentioned that
the ti vote goes to the amended one I
don't see that in here
so where would you come up with that
that's my
question um thank you representative for
your question so on line six and
seven if I'm reading this right uh it
says the receiving the higher percentage
of
yes will be adopted okay um at that
point so there that
will alleviate if there was a tie uh so
one let me just hold on for a
second I'm just trying to because this
we we did when it was submitted we did
change this a couple of times but I I
thought we had in there as for ties
unless I'm not reading this
correctly TI would get
ne I apologize I don't I don't see that
I didn't either representative sellers
so if you look um down
under
13 section
13 okay line 17
through through 18 that's where the
answer lies got it thank you thank you
madam chair it it does say if both
versions of the warrant article receive
the same percentage of yes then the
amended
version of the warrant that shall be
adopted thank you did did I answer your
other part your other question because I
no I just was concurring with okay thank
you I and I apologize I uh I've been
extremely busy this morning to didn't
you have a chance to like this so I
would um point out just to add Clarity
uh you hear me say often that with
regards to the um text of bills before
us we are to f focus on The Bold
language however you will notice that um
under section three of this bill it says
new paragraph So if you look at the
front page of the bill um just as a
reference to to help to remind it says
matter which is all new will re will
appear in regular type so in that
case um that's where we also need to
look
additional
questions the chair recognizes
representative
majority thank you mad chairwoman and
thank you for taking my question I'm
curious how this affects default budgets
um if we go in if the budget is
amended by you know up to 10% of course
it's amended in any way you'll have both
budgets on the ballot one is going to
win and therefore under this bill
default budgets no longer exist if I'm
reading that correctly is that would
would would you interpret it the same
way so when you amend the budget I mean
so you have a proposed budget and a
default budget the only budget you're
amending is the
proposed correct that's my understanding
on a sb2 you you never you cannot amend
the default budget you have an official
budget that comes from the official
budget excuse me I'm
sorry I missed that I was taking notes
so you're good you should
have so in in an sb2 town our official
budget committee will the select board
will send a proposed budget to the
official budget committee which will
then send that official budget to the
public hearing um or to deliberative
session ultimately so we have an
official budget we have the default
budget which is set by the select
board I I think we might be getting
semantics and wording uh because I know
at our sb2 town at school district we
have a default budget which is set in
stone it's last year's budget plus or
minus onetime expenses and so on and
contracts and then we have a proposed
budget which that's the one that is
developed by call it the select board in
this case it was the school board SAU or
and or if you have a budget committee
the budget Committee of the school board
so what I'm saying is the only one when
you go to Warrant when you go to deliver
the session the only one the voters
could actually change would be the
proposed budget they cannot touch that
default budget that was
set yes and I appreciate the discussion
this is a healthy discussion about it
but if we I'm still trying to figure out
how the default budget is even viable
any longer if you have one budget that
one budget that is then
amended you'll then have both of those
budgets on the ballot therefore one of
if I read this correctly and that's what
I'm trying to clarify if one of those
has to win even if there's a tie the
default budget is I'm trying to figure
out if the default budget is still in
play thank you representative I
understand and I understand it gets it's
gets squirly a little bit and I won't
disagree with you because technically
you could say say you have that proposed
budget the original proposed budget now
you get the amended proposed budget and
you still have the default budget so
technically that's how it could actually
go be going to the voters that's the way
I see that you know because you have the
original the amended and then you got
the default I'm hoping someone else can
better explain that but that's how I
look at it and that that could be an
issue I won't disagree thank
you the chair recognizes representative
kazin
thank you madam chair representative
thank you for taking my question for SP2
Town's deliberative session would
this uh basically
remove any motions to stop
reconsideration of Warrant articles
because if it goes to the
warrant it will be reconsidered
thank
you uh thank you for the question is
it's the reconsideration once it goes on
the ballot for the March meeting for the
voters there there is no reconsideration
at that point it would only be the
delivera of session or a town
meeting at that
point uh would actually I would say the
reconsideration is is not off the table
it's still there at delivered a session
in Tom meeting
further questions the chair recognizes
representative Gerard for a
question thank you madam chair thank you
representative sellers for taking my
question I think I actually can try to
help with the question that uh
representative major said because if you
look at line
16 the only time it would go to it would
still go to a default budget it says
that the warrant articles are if are
both approved then the one with the
higher would actually be approved so if
both failed then I believe at that point
then it would go to the default
budget to your point true
yeah further
questions the chair recognizes
representative
Murphy thank you madam chair thank you
representative um
costs um these are unfunded mandates
being put on to the towns and I I don't
know about the ballots but I know for
the accessible voting machine which I
have the paperwork here the cost on it
is between 600 for 1 to five
pages and it's I think it's 650 750 or
850 for the
um for the eight or more pages six or
more pages these are these are that's
just for the accessible voting machine
forget about the other paper and other
ballot they have to be printed for that
and I
don't you know how do you expect the
towns to pay for these and when the when
the election budgets are already at a
stretch thank you uh thank you
representative and of course you being a
moderator which if I remember correctly
you know a lot more in the cost area of
this area um and it does say in the in
the the fiscal notes it says the bill
could result
so um should it have a fiscal note or
not I am not sure
and further questions the chair
recognizes representative Gilman thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question um I want to address uh your
statement about absentee ballots um
there is AOW written testimony at public
hearings I understand uh at there's
nothing for absentee voters at
deliberative session but there is a
result from the deliberative session so
does this bill not uh disenfranchise the
deliberative
session um thank you representative I'm
not quite sure I'm following and I
apologize um I I get that like you said
you can do testimony by hearing but at
the deliver a session all the ones of
you have to be there in in order to make
any amendments or vote yay and nay on
the warrant
Doles Madam chair may I follow up yes
thank you um I guess my point is a vote
is taken at the deliberative session
whether or not there are absentee
ballots um but if the if there is an
amendment at the deliberative
session and we put both of the Articles
the first and the amended version on the
ballot AR isn't the vote at the
deliberative session of the folks that
were at the deliber deliberative session
then um
discounted you know they they've made a
motion and they've changed something why
why
doesn't why doesn't their vote count
thank you represent now I'm following
what you're saying yeah technically they
had their vote at the deliver session
deliver session says yeah let's amend
this warrant article that's the one they
they believe should go forward all right
it's true and you're right their the
their vote and what they have approved
to deliver the session still will go
forward but now it's just given the the
voters that are there or that come to
vote in March I'm using March as an
example come to vote in March or by
absentee
ballot you could say they're getting The
Best of Both Worlds because they weren't
able to make to deliver the session
because they're out of town or in the
service or or disabled
so therefore you know they're able to
vote for either one at that
point thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Elward thank you Madame chairman thank
you representative sers for taking my
question um I live in a small town we
have a very small town hall or venue for
holding deliberative sessions and public
hearings would you say that most towns
and cities in the in the state have a
venue big enough to hold all the
voters um for deliberative
sessions thank you for the question and
I would have to say all the towns I've
ever been at no that's impossible like I
said in our school district there's
about 7,000 voters and gym or Auditorium
might hold five 6 800 people at
most further
questions seeing none thank you
representative sers thank you for your
time thank
you next the chair calls Mr Brody
Dees welcome to Municipal and County
Government
uh thank you to the chair in the
committee for letting me speak today my
name is Brody Dees I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association and um
we are opposed to House Bill uh 149 um
reason being is that we think it would
create confusion and the point of
deliberative session it's the first
session of the town meeting um we
believe that the voters should have a
right to be able to amend warrant
articles and the warrant articles that
are um the ones that end up being on the
warrant without having to worry
competing waren articles um after the
voters have made a decision over what
everyone is going to be voting on um our
other concern is that this is rank
Choice voting for Warren articles um by
having these two different Warren
articles you're essentially establishing
a rank Choice system which would be a
lot to educate our um election officials
on would be a lot to educate the voters
on um in the residence of the of the
municipalities and school districts in
the state of New Hampshire
um we think that um after deliberative
session if the budget was for example if
the budget was amended all of a sudden
there' be two budgets what if both pass
um there might be confusion because not
everyone is going to be able to
understand the law especially if it's uh
passed as written um so for those
reasons um we're opposed and we think
that the current system works the way
it's intended which is allowing the
voters to amend warrant articles in the
first session and then to vote on those
warrant articles in the second session
like a traditional town meeting where
you would have a you would amend a warn
article and then you would vote but albe
it at One Singular session but because
there's a vote by ballot there's a
requirement of a second session in sb2
towns with that I will answer any
questions questions for Mr
Dees the chair recognizes representative
Colby thank you madam chair um how do
you feel this would affect voter
engagement um if voters were to review
the official ballot online and see that
what might normally be uh eight pages uh
is now up to 12 or
14 um I'm I don't think it would
decrease voter engagement because I
think the voters who show up to
deliberative session or to SB to the um
you know in s SP town in sb2 towns to
the to the actual vote um by ballot um
they tend to be the same people I mean
they tend to be the folks who have
always gone to deliberative session who
care there's something that's motivating
them to go there whether it's a budget
or a specific warrant article might be a
nonprofit that's helping to fund rais
for a specific building that's being
upgraded um and the people who go and
vote on the official warrant they tend
to also be the same group of people who
care about their taxes or other things
that the town is doing and they might
not be opposed to any of the warn
articles or at least to the language of
them that are proposed at the
deliberative so um I mean we we don't
view this as in any any way increasing
or decreasing voter participation it's
just making a system that works that's
supposed to mirror to the best of you
know supposed to mirror the traditional
town meeting system of government in New
Hampshire you know2 is not supposed to
be a completely different system it's an
attempt to mirror but allow a vote by
ballot and making it a little bit more
convoluted and confusing to the voters
so what what I think would happen is the
typical voters that are used to the
current system would you know either at
deliberative be confused about the fact
that they've accidentally maybe created
two warrant articles over the same item
and then ultimately the voters will go
to the ballot who say why are there two
and how does this work and then being
confused at the end of the process about
which warn article ultimately passed
so the chair recognizes representative
Murphy thank you madam chair thank you
uh taking my
question the
the lost my train of thought a little
bit
um I'm sorry lost my three that's okay
representative Murphy I'll I'll come
back to you so at this time the chair
repres the chair recognizes
representative
grunt thank you very much Madam chair
and thank you for taking my question um
regarding
uh language of Warrant articles there's
a lot of legal ease that is involved in
those What would happen if there is an
amendment to a warant article that
actually doesn't have appropriate legal
language that's a great point and I
think I had that on my notes but I
forgot to mention it um that would get
confusing you would have a competing War
article where one is legal or one is not
legal it's not worded correctly um and
if the governing body you know proposed
an amendment to the legislative body at
deliberative session to say oh this war
article currently isn't legal we'd like
to make it legal so then it is actually
binding after the vote um all of a
sudden you're going to have an illegal
warant article competing with the legal
warrant article um you know and it
happens there are times where especially
with petition warn articles and where I
know you have a bill that's coming up
later today where we're discussing
intent what's intent and you might even
have a petitioner who shows up and says
well this was my original intent uh I
don't want that to be my intent anymore
I've learned more about this after
putting this in I actually might want it
to do something different or it seemed
like my intent was this but I really
want to do this I'd like to change the
intent so all of a sudden you're going
to have warant articles competing
against each other with varying intents
you're kind of taking the power away
from the legislative body and you're
undermining the whole point of the
deliberative session which is where the
public where the legislative body is
allowed to deliberate before they vote
on the Warren articles and in2 then
there's a second session where it's done
by ballot traditional town meeting it's
done then and there um at the town
meeting the chair now recognizes
representative Murphy thank you madam
chair you talked about education for the
election workers um How much would it
cost for nhma to hold those classes or
for the you can't answer for the
Secretary of State's office or would you
work with them in conjunction with the
Secretary of State's office to educate
all the election workers because it's
that's no small
task it definitely is no small task um
I'm not sure um what exactly nhma would
do in response to this bill passing
that's not really within my role or
purview at our organization I can ask
our executive director about that and
get back to your representative M Murphy
but um I would say I mean that's uh you
know part of the that's a I would say
that's a good reason why the bill should
be voted against because of the herculan
task to try to re-educate not just you
know folks who are helping to administer
these elections but legislative bodies
in every municipality and School
District I mean this would be a
Monumental change to how we historically
have done town meeting in the state of
New Hampshire
additional questions the chair
recognizes representative majori thank
you madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking my question um I'm looking at an
amendment that we have for an executive
bill that we'll have later on today it's
a significant rewrite to the existing
Bill uh if the same thing would happen
at uh when we're at an election day and
you had a significant rewrite to
something would the voter be able to ask
a question of the moderator to get CL
clity or would that be considered
electioneering I'm
sorry confused by the um by your
question only because
um are you are you asking are you asking
about this bill are you asking about
another bill are you just asking about
the general process during deliberative
session the general process on Election
Day if there are two if there are two
articles on the ballot one being a
significant rewrite of the original but
both being there and the voter had a
question about the difference could and
they it's a two-part question really
could they ask a question of an election
official and if they did would that
start to touch on electioneering if
you're describing the difference between
the two
articles that's a great question I would
have to double check whether legal
Council about that but I do know that
there are prohibitions on um how our
election officials are allowed to
discuss things that are on the warrant
so I do know that there are limitations
and um I guess you could you could you
could arguably infer that based on how
they might describe the confusing
situation of two competing warrant
articles that um you might have someone
in the community who wouldd be upset and
try to challenge that they were
electioneering um which would further
kind of Muddy the process but I can look
more into that with our legal counsel if
you'd like me
to at this time the chair recognizes
representative Dolan for a question
thank you madam chair uh in reference to
a question that came up earlier um when
the when the uh deliberative
session ends up
modifying a warant article and renders
it
illegal um uh isn't it true that the
Govern governing body then has a
subsequent
challenge uh to proceed to whether or
not they're going to uh uphold that
warrant article that that if they're
faced with implementing an illegal
warrant article that they have a choice
to uh to implement or to not to
implement yeah so I understand um the
intent of your question if I think I do
um I mean municipalities are going to
bring in their legal council maybe
contact the State and try to figure out
so the governing bodies and try to
figure out how to interpret and whether
or not they're required if it's IL legal
if it's an illegal warrant article but I
think that's part of the um part of the
reason why we have a deliberative
session is so then we can deliberate and
explain you know usually municipalities
or school districts will have their
legal council present to kind of explain
this is why it's illegal this is the
language I've recommended to the
governing body and the legislative body
and this language would now make it
legal so then it would be binding after
the vote and there would be no ambiguity
so um that's why it's usually good
rather than having a competing illegal
and legal warn article to have one one
language that's legal and binding for
the governing body to be able to
implement after the vote should it
pass further
questions the chair recognizes
representative Gilman thank you Madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question excuse me after uh Warren
article is um amended at deliberative
session don't the select board or other
SP2 body um have to re certify their
opinion on it as you as you know as uh
five you know three out of five uh
select board members approve this
measure would they not have to go and do
that they have the original do that on
the
amendment I think it would be reasonable
to assume that you know usually it
happens after the deliberative so they
you know they'll journ the deliberative
but usually the governing bodies will
open a public meeting and then open the
deliberative they'll close the
deliberative and then they'll then re-
reccommend warn articles that have been
changed or choose not to to re-
reccommend because the original
recommendation they still agree with her
there hasn't been changes or amendments
um they they would probably provide
recommendations on an amended warrant
article um so a new warrant article that
would be on the warrant um this is kind
of ambiguous over how that would happen
or you know whether or not there'd be
like a posting requirement that's done
in advance which is something that's
required for all the petitioned and the
um sorry hearing requirement um in
advance which is required for like the
regular warn articles and petition warn
articles so they'd be making a
recommendation on a warn article that
had never received received a public
hearing so that would be an issue
too further
questions I have a question yes so um is
it true that before warrant before
articles are placed on the war the
warrant does not legal counsel for that
body be it the select board or a school
board do they not review the language of
the article before they're printed on
the warrant and then in that case would
they not um you know verify the legality
of the
language yeah certainly I mean you know
municipalities and school districts
they're going to make sure their legal
council reviews it the issue becomes
with petition warn articles an example I
can point out is in wolfboro there's a
warn article to repeal our police
commission um it's currently not legally
written correctly so if if this were to
pass it were to be implemented or were
to be required um in that specific
specific case that I'm citing then you
would have a competing warrant article
one where it's an illegal warrant
article to repeal the police commission
and another that would be legal if there
was an actual change made by the
legislative body during deliberative
sessions so that's kind of the more you
know I wouldn't be worried about the um
the warrant articles that come from the
governing body being illegal but then
there's also the issue of when you get
to deliberative and there's an amendment
made to the governing B's warn article
if the Amendments made would be illegal
then you would have the governing body's
original legal War War article and then
an amended one by the legislative body
that would be illegal so I wouldn't
imagine the issue would be from the
governing bodies worn articles it would
be from either amendments to the
governing bodies or trying to make
corrections to petition warn articles so
they're
legal further
questions the chair recognizes
representative
Murphy thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question the um the the
the warrant article if it's
illegal what's isn't it or petition
warrant article is illegal isn't that
usually mocked illegal on a
ballot I'm not 100% sure I think it
might depend on the municipality uh I
don't know what exactly
um I don't know I'm going to have to ask
her legal counsel about that I'll have
to you know we'll have to have a
conversation I can get back to about
whether or not it's sh it's illegal any
additional questions
um seeing none that it's my final pink
card so at this time I will ask is there
anyone present who wishes to speak on
this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do
so seeing
none we have the blue
sheet Madam chair while I wait for the
blue sheet to come I will say report
that the uh online registration has one
excuse me one vote in support and 11 in
opposition thank you
and Madam chair the blue sheet has two
written um against the bill in
opposition of the
Bill thank you representative Gilman and
with that the public hearing on House
Bill 149 is now closed
thank
you so while we're waiting to get a
little bit organized here I would like
to remind members to pull the
microphones close get intimate with your
microphone 2 in away from your mouth and
slightly lower and then uh with the
discovery of this wheel on the side you
might want to fiddle with that to see if
that might
help okay so this is
that yes
we'll sort that out later maybe she'll
explain
okay so we are scheduled to hear the
next bill at 10:30 we're slightly behind
schedule so at this time I will open the
public hearing on House Bill 230 local
relative to the adoption of Public
Health ordinances by municipalities and
the chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative Harvey bolia to introduce
the
bill chair oh there we go um thank you
members of the committee uh my name is
representative Juliet Harvey bully I
represent Bel bellnap District 3 and um
I uh some of you have heard this bill
before or VAR variations of it
I'm uh introducing House Bill 230
relative to the adoption of Public
Health ordinances by
municipalities and um this body has
heard this bill just about every year I
believe since um 2021 in various
forms um so I apologize if this is like
Groundhog Day to some of you I'm going
to try to go uh swiftly through this the
origin of um this bill the J is is the
mask mandates that some municipalities
enacted after
2021 however please don't pigeon hole
this as a strictly masked mandate bill
because it is actually there's quite a
bit more to it as you will see so um
just a note about the history of this um
like I said since 2021 we've had many
iterations of the bill um um and I can
I'm going to forward you a short history
of the various language Styles and and
what we've how we've tackled this bill
but however this bill has uh in its
various forms has passed the house every
year since
2021 just a
note um so in your first page here
um I we I've Got U by the Aster a more
complete form of this language so you
can see exactly how it looks and I
wanted you to pay attention to the title
which is nuisances TR toilets drains
expectoration
rubbish I think that's important this is
about local
regulations um it's on the top page and
about halfway down there's an aster or
you should have that if you don't have
that I've got some extras here
it says public health so the situation
is that you know many towns after 2021
enacted mask mandates and when I started
to look into the whole process I saw
that it wasn't just sort of mask
mandates that that many people had
issues
with um but it was other issues as well
as far as it seemed like uh
municipalities were using this section
of law 147 colon 1 to uh to enact all
kinds of things um and I'll I'll show
you why um so it says the health
officers of the towns may make
regulations for the prevention and
removal of nuisances and other such
regulations related to Public Health as
in their judgment people the people
require I want to just draw your
attention to a couple things nuisances
is is cited here now nuisance some
people would say that too much paperwork
is a nuisance however when you're when
you're examining land use law nuisance
is narrowly defined as the use and
enjoyment of property that's related to
property use not Public Health at large
such as communicable diseases there is a
distinction
um and the other thing here that I want
you to notice if you will is that there
is no requirement for a public hearing
so in other
words some municipalities were enacting
are enacting certain Public Health
regulations with without a requirement
for a public hearing um being given here
it says Rec the um they they can draw up
and draft
regulations after and and they shall
take effect after being approved by the
Selectmen and recorded by a town clerk
and then they are published but there is
no requirement at all for a public
hearing so that makes leads me to
believe that this section was drawn up
to deal with such things as nuisances
toilets drains rubbish and waste which
are
common um aspects of nuisance law and
not to tell people they can't have
visitors in their homes they have to
wear masks in their own home in some
cases um and uh also to use it to gate
possibly gatekeep uh certain businesses
from coming into the tents all right
so I'm just going to if you flip it
over um on the back I've just got some
examples um and this is the town of
handovers mask mandate they are citing
Authority New Hampshire RSA 147 colon
one now it's pretty exhaustive and this
isn't the whole um I'm going to email
you the whole um just trying to cut down
on the paper so this is an
excerpt uh but it just gives you an
example of how it is drawn up without uh
now many towns did have public hearings
so I do want to make a note that the
towns for the most part that I examined
and I've been to some of the hearings um
in some of these towns as they were
enacting m mask mandates they did hold
public hearings but then they and people
objected to the mask mandates
but there wasn't any redress that they
knew of there that's another thing about
this section of laws there's no redress
if if if the town's uh if the citizens
are unhappy I it doesn't really say how
to to remedy that um so that's why I
again say that there this 147 colon 1 is
really meant as an issue to address the
property related nuisances that you're
all so familiar with pests bugs rubbish
offensive uh smells or noise not
necessarily noises but that sort of
thing um and so there's an example of
the Mask mandate on the back of the
first page and then I've also
included um this ordinance number 40
also from the town of Handover and this
is where
they um
and if you open it up I've sort of
highlighted on the bottom of the second
page where they are limiting gatherings
in people's private homes uh to fewer
than 10 people not including the people
on the property and they also want you
to keep
lists contact information uh this is in
your private home uh which is really
remarkable to me that it went that
far um and as you can see it's not there
is there's no clear end date here on
number six it just says that it will
take effect t uh it will remain in
effect until the public health emergency
is declared no longer in existence as
some of you know a lot of times these
Public Health
Emergency uh statuses in states or
federal government are kept going long
after the emergency is run its course
because
there's funding that's coming in from
various places
okay so what I have done in
um House Bill 230 is we have looked at
this and approached it Fromm so many
different ways but finally last year I
think we finally found something that
seems to satisfy everybody on board um
for the most part is we've left it still
quite
vague I mean this language to me is
probably more vague than I I feel
comfortable with it to be honest H with
you but the Senate um attorney had
helped us draft this um and it simply
strikes out in anything else because we
obviously we don't want
any you know it doesn't pertain to any
sort of Public Health um issue
whatsoever that's this not in the scope
of this section of Law and it limits it
to nuisances and other similar threats
so it still leaves some some room there
for any sort of thing that might come up
but it makes it clear that it's nuisance
likee or nuisance
adjacent issues that we're we're trying
to address
here and briefly while I have your
attention is I'm just drawing um some of
the other things
here is um where people municipalities
kind of went off as as towns towns like
Salem and Atkinson and some other
are using this section of law 147 and
they are citing it to regulate tattoo
parlors in a way that prohibits any
tattooing any tattoo parlors from
operating in town unless they're
operated by a medical
physician please let me know and uh if
you don't have that I will send you the
whole article it's quite long here this
this example but it just says um
um know regulate tattoo parlors and um
no one shall be uh no tattoo parlor
shall operate unless they are operated
by a physician now is this gatekeeping
or is this public health because that is
already we already have a license
process in effect for um a Statewide
license for tattoo parlors and and and
that that includes body piercing as well
and
I think that is this it and I'm happy to
take um
questions are there any questions for
the prime
sponsor the chair recognizes
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman thank you for taking my
question um I just want to make sure I I
understand I if if the if what you're
trying to do for one RSA
1471 is to narrow the scope to
nuisance I'm wondering how the health
officer is going to go
beyond toilet strains um and everything
else listed in the title if you include
the word similar I'm I'm I'm hoping you
can explain where the limit if you're
trying to limit which I understand and
and I get that doesn't similar kind of
blow the walls out a little bit to
anything or does it rain it into only
these one two three four five
issues thank you very much and that is a
fantastic question represent majori um
that is a valid question and I am um
again this wasn't my wording but the
Senate's and if it were up to me I would
probably just leave it to nuisances and
if the committee wishes for that sort of
amendment I will gladly draw up that
sort of amendment that limits it to
nuisances um I'm just left it in because
that this uh variation of this this
language passed in the
Senate um passed in both both bodies I'm
sorry for saying Senate and um so I
thought I'd start there but if you were
if anyone is willing to to uh go with
just nuisances and make it absolutely
clear what it is then I I think that's
actually an improvement thank you
further questions
representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question um if you wished the language
to
[Music]
be more specific than the language that
you are presenting to us today why
didn't you present that to us
today um thank you for the question
representative stavis um
I I guess I wasn't clear but I was just
in my former comment I said that this is
the language that the Senate was happy
with we had a more strict
version um and more strict versions have
been passed by this body um however I'm
trying to um also make the Senate happy
so it's it's a it's a placee keeping
bill and I am certainly willing to um
entertain an amendment to it but I
wanted to get the
committee's plots on it and their
feelings about it does that
help further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair calls Mr
Wayne um
Whiteford
witford welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam
chair good morning Madam chair members
of the committee my name is Wayne
Whitford I am president of the New
Hampshire Health offic Association and
I'm here to address the committee on
house bill 230 uh revising
147-151 of
1471 uh is adequate and does not need to
be changed we do not see any advantage
to uh a change in uh in the particular
sentence that it is a and so we oppose
this
bill perfect
testimony short and sweet any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair recognizes Mr Brody
Dees thank you for taking my testimony
today my name is Brody Dees and I
represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and um we have been opposed
to this bill in its different iterations
for the last few years and we are again
opposed to um House Bill 230 as it's
currently written uh to the point of the
previous testimony we also agree that
language is vague and difficult to be
difficult for municipalities and their
health officers to be able to interpret
and to be able to um to apply um we also
um
specifically the term other similar
threats to Public Health we think that's
very ambiguous um right now the current
language that says and such other
regulations relating to public health is
pretty clear about um the fact that the
regulations need to be related to Public
Health um other similar threats would
seem to kind of open up to a even
broader interpretation actually of what
public health officers would be expected
to um or allowed to regulate um so with
that I will end my testimony and I'll
take any questions thank you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you oh oh I'm sorry I didn't see you the
chair recognizes representative stavis
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question does New Hampshire
Municipal Association have
guidance on the the word
similar uh because what we heard in the
um presentation of the bill was a desire
to narrow the scope of what public
health officers can do but the word
similar to
me has no meaning in law and I'm
wondering if there are similar if there
are other uh statutes or chapters in
which the word similar is used and how
it has been interpreted in those
statutes to my knowledge I don't think
we have any legal guidance on the word
similar or how uh municipalities should
interpret the word similar I mean you
know a lot of different statutes that
could possibly use the word uh and it
would depend maybe on the statute in the
context of the situation um I think you
know we had an internal conversation and
you know while while we uh don't want
the legislature to restrict the ability
of municipalities and their health
officers to establish regulations to
promote um public health because
municipalities have a duty to their
residents to promote the the general
welfare and the safety of the uh of the
of their residents um you know it's one
of those things where if while this bill
isn't intended to be just for mask
mandates it's one of those things where
that has been the main impetus and it
would probably be easier for
municipalities and the health officers
to understand the intent of the of the
statutes if they were updated if it was
explicitly just stated no masking
requirements um or regulations could be
adopted by the health officers or the
municipalities that to us while we
wouldn't support that would be a much
more clear and easy to interpret in
statute versus the term or other similar
threats to Public Health which in in my
mind could be construed um to still
allow for mask mandates so as it's
written because because you know someone
could argue that disease is a nuisance
and that you could adopt in in you know
that you could still adopt regulations
for the prevention and removal of that
nuisance so um I don't know if the bill
currently has written would even prevent
what was the original impetus for
updating the statute back starting in
2021 you know we know there's been a few
iterations of this thank you that was
terrific answer to my question further
questions seeing N I have one oh I'm
sorry I need to I think they're jumping
late on you keep looking both ways
longer the chair recognizes
representative Gilman thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
testimony
um this uh ordinance as it is uh uses
the word
regulations um but it's titled Health
ordinances and forgive me if I haven't
read all of chapter 147 but
um in my town when we change an
ordinance we have to have a public
hearing we have to have an opportunity
for the public to um speak for or
against it is that not a um is that just
our local issue or is that an issue for
every town and City I hav't reviewed the
the um the statute uh recently um RSA
147 chapter so I'd have to review but I
can get back to to see if there is a
public hearing requirement um but I
can't say definitively at the
moment further
questions so I had
one it could you clarify my
understanding is it true that with
regards to ni Hampshire law if a
particular term is not defined under
statutory
construction and or a particular term is
not defined within the particular
section of law then
the Webster dictionary I think it's from
the 1960s is what is the common
understanding that we look to for the
definition of any word that might be
appear in statute or a
bill I am unsure I don't know if that's
the case um I can ask our legal counsel
about that I'm not personally an
attorney I just know that it's more than
just um our opposition to the phrase is
that um it's not just the word similar
it's the entire phrase while similar is
kind of the key word it's just it's
open-ended um I think the term similar
would isn't you know kind of implies
that it could be open-ended and for
broad interpretation based on what
someone would think in the context of a
situation what is similar what's similar
to me for something might be different
to someone else and um I think some of
the issues that this bill is trying to
address um is to try to create some
uniformity and um this wouldn't at least
our interpretation this wouldn't create
uniformity and um how people treat um
you know regulating to Public Health so
thank you further
questions okay that was my last pin card
so at this time I will ask is there
anyone present who wishes to speak to
the bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none we will
get the blue
sheet and the chair will recognize
representative Gilman for that report
thank you Madame chair uh the online
testimony shows uh
123 um in support of the bill and seven
opposed and I would suggest reading the
text on the many many many of the
signning
and today's blue sheet has uh two signed
in as opposed to the Bill thank you
madam
chair and with that the public hearing
on House Bill 230 local is now
closed for
so next on our agenda for today we have
schedule for 1050 House Bill
339 and we don't see the prime sponsor
present so representative state Davis
will introduce the
bill so at this time I will open the
public hearing on House Bill 339
relative to Municipal Master
plans thank you representative
stavis thank you madam chair and
honorable members of the committee I am
my name is Laurel Davis I represent
Lebanon in Grafton County and I would
like to introduce to you today House
Bill 339 relative to Municipal Master
plans this bill expands the scope of the
master plan to include preservation of
agriculture land and promotion of food
production Enterprises as well as any
other relevant
topics thank
you and you're not taking questions
so I do not have any pink cards for this
um for this particular
bill and I will ask is there anyone
present who wishes to speak on the bill
that has not filled out a pink card so
seeing none do we have blue
sheet yes Madam chair uh the online
testimony is uh six in support of the
bill and two posed
and Madame chair for the uh blue signup
sheet we have uh two entries for uh
support of the Bill thank you
representative Gilman and with that the
public hearing on House Bill 339 is now
closed e
next scheduled we have House Bill 407
for
1110 so at this time I will open the
public hearing on House Bill 407 setting
a minimum threshold for the adoption of
town and school budget and spending
items for towns using a ballot to select
such methods during town meeting
and I welcome representative Barry to
Municipal and County government as the
prime sponsor to introduce our his bill
to us today thank you madam chairman
thank you members of the committee um
very quick bill today I was actually
hoping it would go to election law but
it's totally fine it came here um so as
you guys as both sides have heard from
the last election property uh voters are
screaming about property taxes so I was
trying to look at through the lens of
election law um it came here but I was
trying to look through the lens of ction
law of how a bill that I could put
forward that might help alleviate some
of these concerns and when I you look at
local elections U most of which are held
in March um this bill would only deal
with the towns that are using ballots um
so this wouldn't really apply to cities
but it's when you look at those local
elections they are notoriously low
turnout um some of them are even like in
single digits less than 10% voter
turnout and the kind of the conundrum
you face elections is the irony is that
March election really impacts the voter
more than any other election um It's
kind we say this all the time in
election law but nobody really wants to
acknowledge it that local election you
interact with your local government more
than you interact with any other form of
government state federal County um you
know so you have 84% turnout in the last
presidential election they all show up
and they vote for four Electoral College
votes that may or may not matter um but
but then they just ignore uh the vote
that actually sets their personal
property taxes um which is the one that
they then go on um the very social media
and complain about so I started looking
at that and I looked under the lens of
this is a very low turnout election and
you know this body has always valued
local control so the question I've
always raised this is when is local
control not local control right well
it's not local control when you know you
have low teen singled digigit voter
turnout showing up and then setting an
agenda that affects you know 85 70 to
80% of everyone else and there's a
variety of reasons why there's low voter
turnout in those elections um and this
will not cure that I don't pretend that
it will cure that um but what I would
like to do is set in a minimum threshold
for when we're adopting these budgets or
these ballot measures that we're at
least getting a certain level of turnout
um so that a tiny minority is not
imposing its will on the majority so the
way this bill would work um it's very
simple it's you have to have if there's
a me if there's a measure me a budget
whatever let's just call it measure a
for the sake of argument um if there's
measure measure a would need at least a
it would need a majority of those
present and voting to pass that's
current law you need a majority of those
present and voting to pass but of the
people voting for it that that that yes
vote needs to be at least 15% of the
registered voters so at least 15% of the
registered voters need to show up and
say yep we want to do that um and they
have to have the majority of those
um present and voting and the reason you
have to add those reason you have to
have those two Provisions is you can't
just do a baseline turnout because if
you do a baseline turnout you say you
have to have at least 15% turnout period
right if you if you do that you
encourage non-participation because by
staying home you actually are making it
harder to hit the threshold so this is a
way to encourage people to show up they
you won't discourage them from voting um
but I think it will ALS so at least make
sure that if we're adopting ballot
measures that they are there's at least
a very low minimum of registered voters
saying yes this is fine um so you know I
know I know how conquered Works it'll
probably take years for this sort of
concept to to sink in but I do think
it's something that we should look at um
so that we don't have a tiny minority
imposing its will on a majority um and I
kind of want to give excuse once again
election law guy here so I'm kind of
going to give an example of uh these
elections aren't inherently equal in the
people that are interested in them right
so let's say there is a a measure to
give uh the school 10% pay raises right
um measure comes it's going to be in the
budget right it's going to be part of
the school budget well the teachers
union is very incentivized um in fact
it's its job right to go and advocate
for that position right and they get
dues from their members um so they're
going to participate in that election
they're going to encourage their members
to vote they're going to encourage
voters to vote they're going to Advocate
their position that is their right they
are totally that's not a problem that's
totally their right to do that the
problem is is the people who will be
impacted on that are not as incentivized
to fight it financially so uh give you
an example let's say um in my proposal
this pay increase would result in a
teacher getting an $8 to $9,000 pay
increase but it may only raise my taxes
$500 well if I'm going to go and
participate in the election at the same
level that the teachers union is
participating they're they're using
money they're sending mailers they're
doing whatever right they're
participating in the election as is
their right um I then have to decide am
I going to spend the the most that I can
spend to justify my my my going into
this election would be 500 bucks because
that's the most I stand to lose in
theory as a taxpayer right obviously
that's just opposed with the fact that
you're going to be getting better
Services too so that 500 $ is not really
$500 it might internally be like $250 so
these aren't Fair fights um when it
comes to these local levels with who's
participating and you're never going to
be able to seek absolute balance um
you're never going to be able to get
perfect balance in the political process
it's just not possible um but I I do
think when it comes to these sort of
things that we should be having a
process where at least enough people are
participating that we can kind of
credibly say the public wanted this you
know you're not I didn't set this at 5%
have to do it I didn't say 50% turnout
you know I set a really low bar of 15%
of the voters need to show up and say
they want this and they need to be in
the majority and um you know I I say all
the time and I'll kind of end my remarks
with this is you know when are the the
way we do our town budget is a
democratic process um we don't have a
democratic form of government we have a
republican form of government but our
town government is actually very Dem
Democratic it's it's we literally have a
budget and it's direct Dem Ry and people
show up and they vote on it that that is
that is actually the definition of a
democracy of something that is direct
like that um so when does a democratic
process yield a non-democratic outcome
well when you have really really really
low turnout so my hope is that by
setting a threshold both sides will
engage more and the turnout will go up
and this 15% won't even be an issue um
because the turnout will will escalate a
little bit this won't be the the panace
of cure all for that there's other
problems that occur with it but I do
think that if we're going to be raising
property taxes which is what spending
does spending raises property taxes if
we're going to be doing that I think we
should have some semblance of the
consent of the Govern um and I by
setting a minimum threshold for people
showing up in voting yes um I think you
get closer to that admittedly not
perfect and with that I'm willing to uh
take the arguments about why I'm
horribly wrong which I'm sure about to
come so thank you representative Barry
questions
the chair recognizes representative
stavis for a
question thank you madam chair hardly
know where to begin representative
there's a lot in there right it's it's
like a like a six six line bill but it's
it's like whoa that's a different
concept are you saying that if
14% of Voters turned out to pass a
certain warrant
article that would be illegitimate if if
this law were to pass and would those
people not be disenfranchised from their
votes uh no because there it's you know
the it's a great example you give
representative and uh conversely I would
say if one person showed up and they
were the only ones who voted would that
be representative of the body as a whole
so I appreciate the like are you
disenfranchising it um the reality is is
there's you're really you're you're
approaching more of an oligarchy when
you get very low turnout where very few
people are making the decisions so I
want to try to encourage people to show
up and vote and I think if people if
there's a minimum threshold of you got
to show up and say yes to get this done
um you know I I think that's different
and we do use there's this not the only
example of a minimum threshold in New
Hampshire law um many of you will
probably remember the case out of cin
where they showed up at deliberative and
they slashed the school funding in half
right and you know once again it's an
example of a minority in imposing its
will on a majority through a process
that doesn't that is in fact in theory
Democratic but didn't yield a democratic
outcome right um and what happened is
the community came together they had a
huge vote um they had to get at least
50% of the registered voters there right
to then undo what they did in
deliberative so we actually do have
thresholds built into into other parts
of New Hampshire election law um we just
rarely see them and the great irony is
is we only see them when a Democrat
process yields a non-democratic outcome
so I'm trying to kind of work in that
same vein of how do we get a democratic
process to yield a democratic
outcome further questions the chair
recognizes representative
Dolan thank you madam chair
and if
the thank you representative for taking
my question if the if the election
doesn't meet the
criteria then that would seem to render
the default budget to to to fall into
place which we we know in in
today's uh situation sometimes the
default budget is even more than the
proposed budget is that is that the uh
understanding that you have also that
that's my understanding and it certainly
is an outcome and in my town of wear um
the school budget put forward is
actually lower in the first year uh than
the default budget would be um but
you're you're you're acting change right
now normally let's be honest normally
it's an increase right um the cases
where the default is lower than the
proposed is not imposs but it's not the
normal um so once again to my underlying
point of I'd like to see some this uses
some restraint measure on property taxes
I think in the majority of times they
would have that case uh in the case I
just referenced in wear with the school
budget the
proposed school budget is lower than the
default budget but when you break open
the transportation contract you realize
that years two three four and five would
actually be an increase over what the
default budget would do um and that's
not a trick or nobody's playing dirty
it's just one of the things like unless
you know to look down the road you you
you you would think that it's lower but
in most cases the default budget is
lower uh and I think we're handling
legislation obviously we're not talking
about other legislation right now but I
think we're handing legislation that
would address that concern as well um
but that doesn't come for me so don't
ask me questions about it thank you the
chair recognizes representative
Colby thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um collective
bargaining Agreements are placed on
ballots uh as warrant articles should
these warrants not pass then a special
meeting would be
required um if at the time of the
special meeting less than 15% of Voters
uh participate and say yes uh what would
the next steps be for a municipality
yeah uh so uh I don't think that's built
into this it certainly wasn't my
intention to go after the meetings uh
the deliver sessions I have my own
issues with those but it's not trying to
address that in here I'm trying to aim
for the town vote um so you know
honestly if they if they don't do it
what you what the committee does after
that I leave it in your best um best
interest I want to propose the concept
and understand once again I said in my
testimony I understand how conquer works
is if we talk about it enough we might
be able to work it in in the future but
probably not here
further questions the chair recognizes
representative Guth three Guthrie I got
you I got you thank you madam chair and
I really if really you just indicated
the
concept uh do you feel that uh people
have the right not to
vote oh certainly they do representative
Guthrie and I actually have dealt with
that before in election law um I would
make the statement let's say you have a
15% voter turnout I would probably make
the statement that 85% of the voters
didn't choose to stay home they but just
with the way we've set up our town
elections is you know we've every single
town has the right to choose a partisan
ballot not a single town in New
Hampshire has done so um when you leave
those sort of things off of the ballot
the average voter is um kind of unformed
on these issues it's just it's not a
condemnation of people it's just it's a
fact of life is they elect people like
us to try to go and make decisions and
we're supposed to be hyper informed but
they've left these Town ballots with the
way they're set up and the information
that goes out with them and I know the
town sends out a mailer um but they kind
of left these things to where most
voters don't know what to do and to
representative Dolan's point is if the
default budget might be higher than the
proposed budget but in the case of where
I happen to know that the default
budget's actually better than the
proposed budget even though it's lower
even though it's higher um there's a lot
of moving pieces here but I think
ultimately my goal is try to get more
people to participate and I don't think
they're participating due to lack of
Interest I think they're participating
due to lack of understanding and I do
have other bills that won't go through
this committee that try to demystify
that process a little bit um but you
know it's like with anything not
everything's going to pass so you try to
take multiple runs of things follow up M
yes I mean I'm just trying to uh think
about what could happen if you uh people
went to vote and they you got you got
less than
15% you're penal penalizing those people
who did show up because they didn't get
enough people there to vote and do you
think that's a good concept uh well they
didn't they didn't get enough people
there to support something with be I
would look at it right so for whatever
reason their argument wasn't convincing
enough to get at least 15% of the town
to go and do something so their argument
was either unconvincing or people didn't
know about the election once again
another problem with our town elections
is they're held over multiple months so
every Town's got a different one and
they're you know it's not like with the
state general election where everybody
knows it's the first Tuesday after the
first Monday in the even Year everybody
knows the whole state goes and votes
there's a big campaign around it there's
just not that turnout because we've let
this town process just be kind of every
Town's a little different we have fp2
towns they're all little they're all
convoluted some of them are doing Town
meetings some of them are doing Del
sessions right they're all there's this
local control option which is great but
because it's not uniform because the
process is kind of mystified you get
this really really low turnout and in
that situation a minority can impose its
will on the majority and that's what I'm
trying to not solve because this
wouldn't Solve IT solving it would
require 50% to turn out and vote Yes
right that would that would be a true
consent of the Govern right but I also
live in the reality that that's never
going to happen either but I think 15%
is such a low threshold uh that it's
almost it almost shouldn't be an issue I
mean if the committee wanted to amend it
to anything it's there's really like
what number would you pick should it be
1% 2% should it be if one person shows
up and they're the only one who votes
that they get to decide the town budget
for everybody else right at at some
point they turnout so low that the
results not legitimate right and that's
and that's what I'm going after is if we
don't get more people voting in these
things you're not getting an actual
Democratic outcome and I would hope that
everyone in here would want Democratic
outcomes in our Democratic process I
would assume if I went through and asked
you would all say Yes um so I'm trying
to get to that underlying point of how
do we get an outcome especially on
things as important as property taxes
that appear to be more democratic um so
you're at least you're getting some
consent of the Govern because that is a
core part of a democracy is having
consent of the
Govern further further questions yes
no representative Gilman thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question um I understand the
this bill is trying to um get some real
uh weight behind spending items um my
question
is budgets uh proposed and default are
in one article so what H what budget do
you get if only 133% of the voters turn
out so what I sent to OS and I didn't
get a chance to rewrite because I was on
was one of the people that got caught up
in the deadline um was I I I said go it
would go to default so it's spending a
stand R would fail right so if they were
doing you know a new community center
right uh that would just fail and the
budget would go to default that was my
intention with the
legislation I had to it was one of those
uh you either get to take this or not
sort of bills so I took what I had and I
figured I would go and plead my case and
see what you guys wanted to do which I
also live in reality so the chair
recognizes representative
France thank you madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question um
pardon me for being ignorant in this but
do small towns that aren't sb2 have
default budgets I've never been aware uh
I believe they do but I could be wrong
on that I I wouldn't like I said I don't
I don't pretend to understand the
workings of that at that level that's a
uuy thing um I I said I intended this
bill to come through my committee where
I would just work on the election law
part of it and then hand it off to you
guys and you guys would solve those
details so um but I think the my guess
is the speaker looked at this and saw I
had 75 bills and went we'll go over here
first but I said I'm I'm here to answer
the uh the process part of it and you
guys with understand that every single
one of you has a knowledge of that much
deeper than mine I would never I
wouldn't even try to compete with you on
that did you have a followup followup
please yes um so in a small town if you
don't have the
turnout of the
15% does that mean the budget just
doesn't pass and you'd have to have
another meeting so um that's once again
that's a process question for you my my
u um I I break that down the size of the
town does not matter because it's a
percent of the registered voters so the
size of the town is totally irrelevant
it's not you need 100 voters showing up
it's you need 15% so the size of the
town is it doesn't matter it could be it
could be marac um it could be London
Derry doesn't matter um it could be
dickville Notch I just most of the
township but you get my point um you
know how you guys would handle the
implications of it I would actually
leave it up to the committee because
every Town's a little different once
again this doesn't even apply to cities
cities don't vote on their budgets um
that's done by a city council so this is
actually just going after a very Niche
people who've chosen the town balloting
system um to adopt budgets and where it
goes from there you know there obviously
needs to be a budget they can't just
cease functioning you definitely don't
want what happen conversely you don't
want what happened in Cordon where in
deliberative session you know 15 guys
show up and uh and cut your school
spending in half so
additional questions the chair
recognizes representative
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you represent for taking my question um
so do you think there could actually be
an incentive for people to not show up
because if they don't want to vot if
they want the votes to fail if they want
the spending to fail why would they show
up that's why thank you for raising that
question and Madam chair not to be rude
I have to go to my work here in a minute
so I could one more after this I'm not
trying to dodge as you could tell I
could love to have this for a while I
enjoy this conversation I specifically
wrote it in a way to where that wasn't
an issue um so the reason it's written
in the way is because it's 15% voting
for it to pass so staying home does
nothing staying home does nothing
because if 15% show up and say yes and
you want to vote no you still need to
show up because you could be if you have
a if you have 30% turnout right
you could be the 51st vote percentage
wise that stops the majority so this the
way it's it's it's specifically written
to to not encourage people to stay home
it's specifically written in a way to
encourage people to vote but the people
who want the spending to pass are
admittedly more encouraged to show up to
vote um but there is no there is no
bonus for staying home that that doesn't
Advance your cause at all and in fact
because you need a majority uh it
actually because the people wanting the
spending need a majority it actually
encourages people who are against the
spending to show up as well because they
now know that the other side is going to
be showing people up the whole thing is
designed conceptually to drive
turnout thank you at this point the
chair recognizes representative Murphy
thank you madam chair thank you
representative what about petition
warrant articles that have money
involved yep uh so my intention was to
include that in this in this is if it's
a spending item you need 15% and a
majority you need 15% voting yes and
that 15% needs to be larger than the
no and I I I do I I really I'm happy to
come back if you guys want to keep
calling this but I I my my staff's going
to start calling me ask me where I'm at
I'm already late representative Barry is
would it be okay if um not sure how to
handle this we have a few other
questions could could he give the
question to me and I could forward it to
you
you can distribute the answer to
everybody yeah I'm I'm happy to answer
it but I got to go I got to go watch is
that okay representative jard or anybody
else that has a question all right
funnel it through me I'll pass it to
representative Barry and I'm sorry to do
that to you guys I normally love
answering questions I just I literally
have people watch get an answer for you
thank you representative
Barry at at this time the chair
recognizes Mr Brody Dees
um again for the record uh Brody desay
representing the nire municipal
Association I appreciate you guys taking
my testimony uh this
morning yep it's still morning just want
to check um we the New Hampshire
Municipal Association is opposed to um
House Bill 407 I I think the most cinct
way I can start is you can lead a horse
to water but you can't make him drink I
mean SP2 towns can have uh preliminary
hearings and the hearing requirements
for their warrant and their budget um
they can post these warrants publicly
well in advance of the deliberative they
can discuss and deliberate at the
deliberative session and then they have
you know typically a few weeks up to
maybe even over a month for the
community to write to the newspaper to
influence each other influence the
governing body Etc on the final boote on
the final vote um SP2 has never had a
quorum requirements and this bill would
it would impose a quum requirement and
that's one that's not done for
traditional Town meetings and to kind of
treat the two as dissimilar processes is
um kind of not in Tradition with what
the legislature has historically done
what towns have supported and what I
think the voters and the residents of
New Hampshire have expected um we also
think people's lack of Interest or you
know to the representative who spoke
before he claimed understanding we think
it has more to do with interests because
if they were interested they would
follow the process and Gain
understanding um it shouldn't overrule
the will of the voters who are willing
to show up and participate in the
process um because people don't show up
it doesn't mean they are opposed either
there are some people who say you know
I'm busy that week or I'm out of town or
ET they have a myriad of reasons we
could never imagine every single
individual Granite stator's reasons for
why they do or don't show up to um to
vote at uh at the second session in SP2
towns for town
meeting um I do want to point point out
the um not just the whole issue of
having a quorum requirement and it being
imposed and that being a uh a a
restriction on communities I I do want
to point out two major technical issues
one is it calls in the question whether
anything like a default budget or a
collective bargaining agreement could
pass because 15% of people may not show
up but all of a sudden you have
14.99% of people show up um arguably
nothing can pass I mean because You'
have you have a quorum requirement the
second session of s SP2 essentially it's
n and void for the most part there's
also something uh Worth to be said and I
bet some of the moderators on uh your
committee would understand is the term
registered voters in the town that is
not the phrase that's used typically um
for SP2 of how many voters are able you
know were are registered um with the
town it's actually um it's actually the
checklist that's post posted the Friday
before um voting so you'd have to use
that specific phrasing so even for towns
to try to implement and figure out what
is
15% they wouldn't you know the the voter
checklist that they have is not um
necessarily you know this term this
terminology doesn't jive correctly with
the existing
statutes um and I'll kind of end too is
that um communities If This Were to pass
I would imagine would get very concerned
about being able to have these quorums
and um it might incentivize the
governing body to try to return back to
traditional town meeting and the purpose
of s SP2 and it was originally passed
was to try to encourage participation in
the process and to try to make it easier
for towns um and for their residents to
be able to vote so you know we you know
we've seen a lot of bills that have come
before this committee to try to change
the process for SP2 towns and how they
conduct their um their annual Town
meetings and you know it makes the most
sense to try to create some to make sure
that the two syst of traditional town
meeting and SP2 towns mirror each other
um as reasonably as possible um as much
as possible so with that I will answer
any questions thank you other
questions representative
Colby thank you madam chair thank you um
for your testimony um I'd like to
pose a question to you and and
definitely okay it's just a hypothetical
um if a grant was tied to a article um
and it's like a 8020 uh for
bridgade under using this language would
the municipality then have to give up a
parent you know a possible million doll
Grant
um because the 15% voter threshold
wasn't
met yeah and thank you for the question
representative under this bill if 15% of
people don't show
up then nothing passes if 15% of people
do show up it still needs to pass but if
you have a warrant article that's
constructed that is we need to raise
this amount of money and appropriate it
to be able to access this Max matching
Grant well the warn article dies doesn't
pass so and again you know having this
cor requirement you know I think the the
biggest concern is that your second
session your town meeting essentially
would be just null and void even if the
voters showed up who show up and want to
participate and care about what's
happening in the community um their
voices would essentially the legislative
body would just be canceled out by other
folks lack of Interest or lack of
concern and um that to us doesn't seem
fair and it could really
municipalities and cities and basically
make all govering functions kind of halt
um so that's a huge concern thank
you for other
questions representative Davis um thank
you madam chair I have a question for
the
chair will this bill go to a second
committee we haven't had that um
discussion as of yet we're in the
hearing so it's
unknown representative majori thank you
madam chairwoman and maybe this is
getting to the weeds and you've just
answered this but even a bond that
received three fifths
and passed but not for not 15% that
would still fail correct if 15% of so I
think the intent is for it to be the the
folks who are on the voter checklist in
the community but it's currently written
that's not the current verbiage or
wording but I think the intent was for
you needed at least 15% of people on the
voter checklist to show up to be able to
pass or to be able to pass any worn
article and so not only would you need
in that case of a bonded one you need
15% cor cor requirements so 15% of those
people on the voter checklist to at
least cast a vote and then you still
then need to meet that three-fifths
requirement as as required in statute to
pass the bonding issue so um I mean you
try to bond something at with this I I
couldn't imagine very rarely would
communities be able to to be able to get
something pass it have to be
um you'd have to do a lot to encourage
your legislative body and the residents
of your community to get out and it'
have to be um something that they're
very passionate about so and not
everyone is as passionate about local
government as all of us in this room
so so representative stavis I'd like to
apologize I misunderstood or
misprocessed your question I thought
that you said subcommittee when um I
clarified it with the vice chair that in
fact you said second committee correct
So my answer was was misguided and
incorrect this bill is has only been
referred to this committee so the answer
correct answer is no it will not go to a
second
committee further
questions no seeing none thank you oh oh
I'm I'm sorry I didn't representative
stavis thank you madam chair I apologize
and this may be an ill-informed question
so I apologize in
advance under Quorum requirement if you
don't meet the Quorum requirement you
can't
proceed so if this imposes a quorum
requirement and 15% of the voters aren't
there can you even have a
vote our interpretation would be yes you
can have the vote because town meeting
is throughout the entire voting day so
you're just you know you're waiting you
know people are showing up as the town
meeting goes on throughout the entire
second session which is the voting day
um but essentially a town meeting
wouldn't have happened once you get to
the end of the day and your supervisor
of the checklist and your moderator and
your town clerk says oh 15% of people
didn't show
up yes so in fact the election really
wouldn't have happened correct
essentially so you'd be uh you'd be ad
minister thank you for the question
you'd be essentially administering an
election and crossing your fingers on a
hope and a prayer that 15% of people
showed up and that actually counted
otherwise um there's no real Provisions
in this statute and I have to review the
statutes more to be completely
definitive of this but how you would go
about addressing Warren articles that
failed that even you know they 14% of
people showed up they passed they might
have pass overwhelmingly but you didn't
meet to quum requirements so you're
going to have to have a special meeting
and obviously special meetings
themselves have qu requirements and I I
do want to if I could address that um
there's a reason why special meetings
have Quorum requirements and that's
because it's the state of New Hampshire
the legislature has decided that if the
governing body or even a petitioners of
the legislative body really want to add
supplemental funds to a budget or
something of that nature or to you know
change the previous outcome of a vote
that you know you're basically kind of
redoing a previous vote and so they want
overwhelming amount of support um in
this case this is kind of the
traditional town meeting structure so
you know you would essentially be saying
yeah without that Quorum requirement um
for the initial uh it's no and void it
didn't really happen
so the chair recognizes representative
Murphy thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
um what going to happen on article one
and article one is the election of all
officers in the town Board of Selectmen
Tom moderator supervisors of the
checklist Trustees of the library
Trustees of the trust fund all those
elections are now null and void didn't
happen you didn't meet the Corum
requirement at the second session then
addition I would imagine the town would
have to pay for those additional costs
for second election yeah know and that's
where it gets really complicated cuz
with the money thank you for the
question and with
I'm going to interrupt so the question
that he
asked pertained to spending items
article one which is election of
officers in the clear text of the bill
pertains to spending items so perhaps um
Mr
des's um missed that so quickly refine
your answer yes thank you no wouldn't be
related because that's not a spending
item and I appreciate the chair's
clarification sorry
additional
questions seeing none right no more
questions thank you thank you and thank
you for the
clarification so that was my last our
last pink card and so I will ask is
there anyone here that's present that
wishes to speak on the bill who has not
yet had had the opportunity to do so
seeing none I will recognize
representative Gilman to report the blue
sheets thank you madam chair uh the
online presence has two votes in support
and 30 in opposition
and the in-person blue sheet has uh
three in opposition and one in
support thank you representative
Gilman so um with that I will close the
public hearing on House Bill
47 so at this time we are ahead of
schedule and we are scheduled to take
lunch until 1 p.m. at which time we will
come back and we will hear two more
bills so with
that I'll come after after you close
this okay so we we're we're going to
break for lunch and we will um resume
our public hearings at 1 pm have a nice
lunch
good for you
up
I think it's but I think be very bad
forgot if it didn't incl
en well
all
red
e
e e
so I can um gauge how much time we're
going to need
here e
sir that just walked in if you have pink
cards could you give them to Mr caraz
representative Kosinski thank
you
e
e e
so good
afternoon public hearings for this
afternoon for those of you who weren't
present this morning when I had morning
announcements I'm going to
repeat some of
those we have right now 14 pink cards
for House Bill
432 so plus the prime sponsor and there
could be more pink cards
coming so the chair has scheduled 20
minutes for this hearing which clearly
is not going to be enough time so as I
um stated this morning for bills um that
the chair Mis guesstimated how much time
we would need need I announced the the
following um Provisions in order that we
stay on time and in order that the
committee receives the information that
you would like to disseminate to us so
what I'm going to do is I will allow for
up to five minutes for the bill
introduction followed by questions and
answers then I will allow up to three
minutes will be given to people uh
providing inperson
public
testimony with additional time for
questions and answers if the speaker
allows so we're going to need to keep
time and the vice chair will do
that once you have uh stated for the
record your name who you represent and
your position on the bill we'll start
the timer when your time is expired look
to if you see a pink card raised that
indicates that we would like you
to um wrap up your testimony in a
sentence additionally if a speaker has
written testimony please indicate such
and pass it to representative Kinski so
that that can be passed along to
committee members if a speaker has more
information that they' like to share
with the committee and you didn't have
enough time to do so then also please
IND indicate that to me and you will I
would like you to follow up with um
written information that is sent to to
the
committee and also I would also um
advise that if you're later in the list
of pink cards try very um try hard not
to repeat what has been repeated simply
say I agree with the previous testimony
um but I would like to add this um that
that will also
help
and I think that covers
everything
okay so at this time um we have
scheduled house bill for 432 to be heard
beginning at 1:00 it is I believe 10:2
so I will open the public hearing on
House Bill 432 relative to recovery
houses so at this time the chair
recognizes representative Gibbs who is
the Prime sponsor of this bill welcome
to Municipal and County
government good afternoon
take your time
um good afternoon um and thank you madam
chair and members of the committee uh
I'm Merill Gibbs uh I represent marac uh
District 23 conquered w nine and I'm
here to introduce House Bill
432 um I have to mention that I'm also
working all day on the Commerce
Committee so I'm trying to keep all the
pieces straight in my head um
I was asked to sponsor this bill by new
Futures which is an organization that um
provides nonpartisan um information and
advocacy um on New Hampshire health
problems um House Bill
432 essentially provides that
municipalities and zoning boards treat
recovery houses the same as all other um
residential housing
um in New Hampshire access to housing
remains one of the greatest obstacles
for people facing substance misuse
recovery housing uh for person's um uh
recovering from substance abuse is
important for individuals uh with this
this this disorder because it provides a
safe and Healthy Living environment data
shows that access to recovery housing is
associated with positive outcomes
including decreased rates of substance
abuse lower chances of reoccurrence and
reduced rates of incarceration recovery
housing provides a bridge between
inpatient treatment and independent
living playing a crucial role in
supporting long-term recovery and
improving overall health it benefits
individuals in
recovery House Bill 432 aims to support
the development of recovery housing
expanding access to these essential
services and addressing the state's
ongoing addiction crisis
sorry housing remains one of the
greatest obstacles uh facing our battle
to overcome the addiction crisis simply
put individuals need safe and supportive
stable housing to achieve and maintain
long-term recovery we have worked hard
as a state to increase access to
recovery housing there are nearly 100
Certified Recovery recovery homes in the
state with a total of nearly 1,300 beds
but to overcome our addiction crisis we
need many
more there are currently no Certified
Recovery houses in Rockingham County and
none in Coos County there are only a
small handful of beds in Sullivan
Grafton and in chesher counties even in
Manchester which has the most beds in
the state there are not enough to meet
the need according to Statewide
projections there is not one community
in our state that has enough beds to
meet the needs of individuals with
substance abuse disorder and our state
would need an additional 15,000 beds to
meet that need to be clear this bill
will not solve the housing shortage but
it will help by supporting the
development of recovery housing around
the state often times when recovery
houses are proposed for development
local zoning and planning boards don't
understand exactly what they are and
what to do with them this
bill aims to remedy that by clarifying
in state law that these are residential
facilities to be zoned and regulated
like other multi-unit residential
facilities as required by the federal
fair housing act this will help cities
and towns to support the development of
this key key resource and also help them
to avoid fair housing complaints
also it will help our communities to
ensure that they have the housing
resources that they need to support
individuals in their localities with
recovery and help us all to overcome the
addiction
crisis
um I'd be happy to take questions uh I
should should point out that there will
be others testifying who may be better
answer better able to answer
um some technical
questions thank you representative Gibbs
that was right under five
minutes questions for the prime
sponsor the chair recognizes
representative
Gerard thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question um
in the line 16 line 17 of your bill you
discuss about the per purpose of this
paragraph recovery house should be
certified pursuant to the RSA within one
year or I'm sorry I can't hear you can
you a little okay I will try um the
question I have is in regards to the
certification process in speaking with a
gentleman who is very uh familiar with
the the process at this point it sounds
like one year is probably a a very long
period of time for this uh because the
concern was that people come in and
start to open up that are not really
doing it legitimately and then they
could close up before the year's process
and not ever have to worry about it is
there how would that be
handled um there are others who are
going to be testifying I think who can
better answer that question than I can
uh Jake Barry of of new Futures is going
to be testifying as are some
representatives of recovery houses thank
you additional questions
seeing none thank you representative
Gibbs thank
you next the chair calls representative
priest welcome back to Municipal and
County
government thank you madam chairman it's
great to be back um I used to sit in the
seat where uh
you are now sitting at the end and it
brings back lots of great memories to be
with you I'm here to support HP
432 I represent the District of 17 in
hillsbough County that is W two for the
city of
Manchester and I have many personal
stories of of constituents in my war
that has children and
grandchildren and relatives who have a
substance abuse program and they go for
treatment and the treatment can be a
month or two months and they leave the
treatment facilities and there's no safe
environment for them
to for their next step and this is a
this bill
represents a way to
clarify recovery
houses and would assist the cities and
towns to do so to encourage them to
permit more recovery houses in their
jurisdictions and as was mentioned
before there is a substantial need for
this in New Hampshire we only have 1,300
beds currently and we need 15,000 beds
more to to accommodate those people who
are recovering from substance
abuse now I know this doesn't solve the
housing crisis there is a committee to
do that but this will address a
significant obstacle that is facing all
of our
communities and the people within them
that have substance abuse addiction
problems so I urge you to approve this
bill um and I will answer any questions
if I'm able to do so thank you questions
for representative
priest representative majori thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you
representative priest for being here
it's always great to see you great to
see you too question about one word um
in the first line in this section
recovery house means
primarily what is the
word primarily
opens the door to doesn't it open the
door to ambiguity about about the exact
definition so I'm curious why is the
word primarily there do you know that's
a good question and I have Jake Barry
behind me who will answer that
question further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you and I have a letter to pass out
thank you thanks
next the chair recognizes representative
Damon welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair good
afternoon committee
members uh for the record I'm state
representative hope Damon I serve
Sullivan District 8 the communities of
aworth langon lemster Goan Washington
Springfield snipe my hometown of Cen and
the City of Claremont hello Mr Mayor
um I am a retired registered dietitian
and now some 30 plus years ago I worked
for about 10 years in what was then
called addiction treatment um and
provided care to people in three
different substance use
disorder uh early recovery
facilities and learned a whole whole lot
then about the reality that folks with
substance use disorder are just like all
of us
there are I'm sure plenty of people in
this building with substance use
disorder and they're just ordinary
people who need help to get in and stay
recovered and be productive members of
society I'm a co-sponsor on this bill
and I vigorously support it the key
points I would remind folks of recovery
houses are not medical facilities the
people who reside in recovery houses
have already achieved recovery and they
are working hard to stay in recovery
the houses are to create a safe
supportive substance-free environment
from which people can live work parent
do all the things that ordinary people
do in life and develop more skills and
more time
frame as people in recovery so that that
becomes their norm and they
work
um and just being concise here I would
just say people often do better when
they are in a in the broader oops
broader Community sense familiar
environment where they have support
systems outside of the recovery home
whether it's family
friends um groups that they participate
in and if you can't find a safe Recovery
House in your community and you have to
go far away that can compromise your
recovery that's not true of every
individual but it is often true um I
think they are very very good for
community and I urge you to take this
thoughtfully and seriously thank you
thank you are there questions the chair
recognizes representative
Elward thank you Madame chairman welcome
uh representative Damon um who assures
on a day-to-day basis that the
individuals are substance
free that is an excellent question and I
am going to defer to the f FKS behind me
who are
more uh immediately expert about
operations the chair recognizes
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman and thank you representative
for taking my question you said U these
are not uh medical facilities correct
would you can they be classified as a
business um I'm not fully qualified to
that answer that question but my
response would be they're not usually
for-profit okay so I think it would be
how what their tax uh category is and
maybe it's not all the
same um further questions the chair
recognizes Vice chairman
McDonald good afternoon representative
um on line three you've got dwelling a
dwelling unit that provides a and you've
crossed out safe and healthy why did you
do
that I am not the person who drafted the
bill but my opinion would be that those
are terms that are somewhat vague and
hard to Define versus substance free is
a very clear
statement okay thank you you're welcome
thank you for the question additional
questions represent FR thank you madam
chair thank you representative Damon for
coming before us uh you may not be the
person to most qualify to answer my
question um typically do the people in
the transitional house pay rent out of
their own pockets is it funded by
Medicaid or some other funding means can
you I'm going to defer the details of
that answer I don't it's the same for
every recovery house um I personally am
not aware of there being Medicaid
funding for it but I would encourage it
ask that question to the folks behind
me and I apologize for not having all
the answers I'm on Ed funding committee
it's been a little
crazy representative stavis has a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question course if um
a medical facility wanted to build
build a Recovery House on its tax exempt
property within a
municipality would that fa facility also
be tax
exempt I don't
know excellent
question further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you all for your time and work
next the chair calls Mr Joe Scully and
following I will call Ms Melinda
Sims welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair and
members of the municipal committee my
name is Joe Scully I live here in
conquer less than a quarter mile down
the road um want to say first that I do
not uh oppose sober living houses I
think they are a great thing when the
proper structure is in place and I I
trust that everyone here behind me to
speak in support of it uh does provide
the the proper structure and has been uh
recipient perhaps of of good structure
my concern is for the Bad actors out
there um and I have a personal
experience with this done some research
and found that I believe there are a lot
of uh people people who are abusing the
system taking taking advantage of
everybody including people who live in
the so the sober living houses and the
neighborhoods around them the reason
that can happen is there are essentially
no rules right now in New Hampshire as
far as I can tell I got involved in this
this past summer when I got a legal
notice from the conquered Zoning Board
of
adjustment uh a a property owner and I
passed out uh momentum properties um was
petitioning for a an exception from
zoning
regulations uh they clearly were already
doing this they were petitioning for
something that they were already doing
they got caught uh my neighbors and I
all came out gave some concerns
including the uh uptake in police
activity that you can see on the police
log since they bought the house there
was there were no calls to that property
in the 10 years prior to them buying the
house as soon as they bought it there's
calls for uh criminal threatening I was
criminally threatened I I potentially by
the that very incident in there uh guy
came uh onto my property as I was trying
to get my four-year-old daughter into
the car and and uh he was he was on
drugs and trying to fight me in my own
yard
um there my my one neighbor spoke of uh
one of the people living in that house
uh sexually satisfying himself uh with
the windows open looking looking into
the other house next door
um the property owner sent his lawyer
who threatened the zoning board and said
if you don't Grant this special
exception we're going to sue you in
federal court for violations of
Americans with Disabilities Act uh so
the board uh following that granted it
he said we'll sue you just like we sued
Manchester and federal court uh some of
the other research which I I only have
one copy of I'm I'm happy to leave
everything I I have here uh so the
committee can can have it but we found
this particular company bought four
houses and conquered all in that same
day from the same previous owners so
while I have not been able to verify if
the other three houses are sober living
houses or not I I suspect that they are
the company was formed like a month
before they bought all these four houses
um I found I'm sorry please let me know
if I'm running up against my time um
there is no requirement as far as I can
tell that sober living house residents
have to prove that they either have
received addiction treatment or have
recently received addiction treatment
New Hampshire does not require that paid
house managers live at recovery houses
or sober living houses as far as I can
tell um you know I've got uh Union
Leader article from back in September a
Manchester property owner is saying that
he needs to be able to put 10 occupants
in a house only zoned for four in order
to be able to make enough money uh Nash
nasua is being sued in federal court by
a Rhode Island based attorney um I I'll
wrap up here but my point is that um
there are almost no rules here and
that's allowing the Bad actors to take
advantage of everybody there are these
they call these things sober living
houses but I I I think I've got some
evidence to show that it it's a place
where drugs can and do um come in
because there's there's no structure so
taking away something um the zoning uh
process so to speak that currently
exists I feel would only worsen the
abuse of the system by The Bad actors
out there so I want to respect
everyone's time um I can stop there
thank
you thank you other questions
representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question thank you for
testifying before our committee would
you agree that so-called Bad actors and
people who abuse drugs could live in not
facilities unlike this one residential
facilities homes could could they live
in res uh yes in fact they they do
that's what's happening in my
neighborhood two two houses down and two
houses over um that is a single family
house zoned for four people that they
now have approval for six people one
bathroom um I I just uh struggle to see
how that is really um a good situation
for the people in there and I I just
view it as that property
owner focusing on being able to collect
more money from six people instead of
four or less in there followup yes Madam
chair so my my question is
that people who abuse substances and act
badly maybe as a consequence of that
abuse can can and do live
everywhere would you agree with that uh
sure and and don't get me wrong I'm I'm
I'm very sympathetic to to people who
have been affected by um addiction and
my comments are grounded and I don't
want to make it worse for them if if
that makes
sense representative Elward has a
question thank you madam chairman and
welcome to uh our committee
today under uh lines 15 and 16 regarding
a recovery house shall be certified
pursuant to RSA
172b colon
2 Roman 5
A2 reads that certification is based on
National
standards do you do you know what
national standards exist for the
certification process I can't say I am
familiar with all of the standards to
become certified now all right thank
you further
questions I have a question sure so I I
I heard heard you um
State a statement with regards to um
zoning a house being zoned for four
people and more than four people um
residing in that particular house that
was zoned for four could you expound
upon that and clarify that and I assume
that that is in the city of conquer do
you have more detail to to what that's
about um
I I I don't have it with me I I can dig
up the documents that were out there
during the zoning process but yeah
basically there was a statement uh
that this is a single family house not a
not a duplex just one unit that
without a waiver or an
exception four it was four people could
live there and in order to exceed that
as a non-family unit they needed an
exception and they petitioned they
petitioned for six while sort of uh
portraying that as as they were doing us
a favor the law gives us the ability to
ask for 10 they said but we're only
asking for six was was what was put out
there during that
time would you be able to obtain that
that reference and email it to me if if
you can uh yes I will thank you thank
you any further questions seeing none
thank you Mr
Scully next the chair calls M Melinda
Sims then it will be followed by
Miss is it Mr is it Connor nor norell
you are correct it is my error somehow
your pink card got in this stack so no I
I apologize so then next the chair calls
I believe it is M Mr Connor nurel is
that
correct and then that he'll be followed
by Mr bro
Dees welcome to Municipal and County
Government thank you happy to be here so
uh this is a a testimonial of my
experiences in sober living uh for
myself uh arguably sober living was the
most crucial point in my recovery
process I am just about to celebrate
three years clean on February 14th
because of it and uh I came all the way
up here from New York because uh the
area that I'm from in New York didn't
have the resources for sober living and
as mentioned before there's counties out
here here in New Hampshire that don't
have the uh footprint for sober living
like nashille and Manchester do so I
work in treatment now and I see the
people that are able to stay in sober
living have the most success but there
are are also the individuals that don't
have the opportunity to stay in the uh
areas that they got clean in they get
pulled back to these counties because
they have an IOP dictated through uh
drug court or whatever the case may be
they get pulled back to areas that they
used in and they have no safe ha
as far as sober living to live in so if
there's a process to speed up uh sober
living houses being put into those areas
and I fully support it and uh will do
speak or say or do whatever it takes to
make that
happen thank you sir are you willing to
take questions I am
questions the chair recognizes
representative
Elward thank you madam chairman welcome
to New Hampshire thank you
um do you happen to know approximately
what percent of individuals using this
um let's call it sober living process um
are
successful so I don't know the exact
percentage but what I can say is there
the percentage always increases so
there's a a detox residential than a
phpop like step of care that they go
through and the percentage obviously
increased inrees with every little bit
that they do more towards their recovery
um anyone that's searching for long-term
recovery should always go to sober
living because everybody will benefit
from it that's where you create your
connection your community and you create
a foothold in your journey to long-term
recovery like I live in sober living
still I've created my own little Network
that we move to our own house we all
live together house to house and kept
upgrading ourselves along the way but we
still stay together throughout the whole
thing I would have never got that if I
didn't go to sober living or continued
with my after care now to take these
you're going to have addicts on the
streets doing what addicts do best
making the other people uncomfortable
all right but if you can allocate the
houses to get them into and whatever
areas it is you're giving the community
a better chance to thrive you're getting
people off the street you're getting
addicts help long-term help because
treatment
ends there has to be more sober living
to to combat that epidemic
further
questions representative
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you for testifying today and
congratulations on your threee of
sobriety that's awesome um could you
describe just briefly because some of
the the one of the questions came up but
what it might look like inside a sober
house supervision wise and what kind of
supports do you
receive so I I did hear that there is no
law to make sober living have a Livin
house manager that kind of thing but I
all the ones I know about in New
Hampshire have house managers they don't
just allow people to come off the street
and go into sober living either there's
there's a a step there's a guide to
things as somebody that would uh
potentially own a sober house I don't
want somebody that's that far uh that
deep into the streets or into their
addiction to move into sober living
because you don't have a good client at
that
point our sober living has house
managers they have regular drug tests
they could be sporadic or at least three
times a week on any given day all right
um they have recovery coaches for
everybody under a year that they get to
see once a week and uh we have uh
meetings that they go to that we hold
in-house at our facility plus around the
surrounding area in Nashua I mean
they're very ingrained in the community
out there they're not just there on
their own doing
nothing additional questions
seeing none thank you thank
you the chair recognizes Mr Brody Dees
followed by Mr
Derek
Peg something Peg
Le we we'll sort that
out uh thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you to the committee for uh taking
my testimony today my name is bro Des
I represent the New Hampshire Municipal
Association we are a nonpartisan
nonprofit voluntary membership
organization um every city municipality
all 234 are members of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and um I am
speaking today to House Bill 432 and
registering our opposition and our
opposition is doesn't really have
anything to do with section one of the
bill has to do with section two because
our organization has historically and
always been against zoning mandates and
um there are some aspects to the changes
of um the of RSA 674 colon 17 um which
is the purposes for zoning ordinances
that by allowing um Recovery House
however it's defined um that's not
really in our wheelhouse defining
recovery houses but how are recovery
houses defined um there'd be certain
exemptions that recovery houses would
have that could pose um safety and
health concerns to municipal ities and
cities and they have an interest in
protecting um the safety and the health
of their residents and um and folks who
live in their communities um first I'll
touch on the um the definition of
recovery house and we had an internal
conversation we had um one of our legal
council kind of review um some of the
statute and it seemed at least from our
perspective that recovery homes while
they're not like boarding houses or
rooming houses or halfway house which is
you know mentioned um later on and and
and uh described and defined I believe
in RSA 151 but um recovery houses still
are transient in nature they have
transient qualities that's what I should
say um they're not intended to be
long-term living for the rest of your
life they are intended to provide
housing stability to people who are
recovering from drug addiction um which
we understand there's a need for that in
our state but um just by changing the
definition removing the term safe
healthy and family like is concerning
when coupled with the second section the
bill and you'll notice that
um on line
12 is it line 12 I want to make sure I
get it right yes on line 12 it says you
know after describing you know multif
family respectively and shall not be
subject to permitting or approval
processes out a zoning ordinance or
other land use regulation adopted under
this title does not similarly require of
such uses and we're worried that that
might mean that considering the health
and general welfare of a community in
zoning um would not be allowed to be
considered and even more um after that
on line 14 um the First full sentence
use of existing multif family structure
as a recovery house and no not that no
yeah shall not require site plan review
um site plan review is a very important
process for ensuring that um that the uh
change of use that that is conforming to
um some of the zoning regulations which
have to do with health and safety
um so without that there's really
nothing for a municipality to be able to
make sure that there's health and safety
requirements or a myriad of other zoning
requirements that every other type of um
commercial or Residential Building would
be subjected to if it did not conform to
the uh zoning of the community the
zoning and the planning um the
permitting process is somewhat of a
concern too you'll see on um line uh 16
um it says or shall be actively pursuing
certification achieve certification with
the one Within one year of beginning
operations so um they wouldn't be
required to even have a certification to
operate um and they could even have up
to one year to get that certification
and most municipalities and cities are
going to want them to be certified to be
able to operate a Recovery House in
their municipality um and that's part of
the reason why it's good to have site
plan review because you're going to ask
that during the site plan review uh
possibly depending on what your local
ordinances are and what your processes
for site plan review um I also want to
mention CU I heard one person who talked
about a um an application that came in
front of either their planning or zoning
board in the city of conquer and um
there is something to be said about
these local processes can be used not
just for Community feedback but also
education right sometimes these folks
that run these organizations are trying
to change the use of a residential um
property into a recovery house they can
help provide education as to why they
believe that um changing the use won't
create a health or general safety issue
in their neighborhood in the residential
neighborhood where it's um being applied
for and
um I think I put on my card only 3
minutes so I'll I'll yield there and
I'll answer any questions to the best of
my
ability
questions representative stavis thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
my question and as you know this is a
committee of nuts and bolts and details
so I don't want to focus on the the
principle here I want to focus on one of
those details and I'm struggling with
the term non-
trangent which is in
line two of the
bill uh can you define for me under what
RSA is this term located and what does
it mean I what I'm struggling with is
the taxation laws that
govern temporary housing coming under
the business tax chapter and how
non-rent fits or doesn't fit into that
category and and what does non-rent
actually mean for purposes of
Taxation that's a great question I would
have to ask her Le it wasn't even
something that came up on our internal
conversations about it um regarding that
term non-transient I'm unaware if it's
in any other statutes there might be
people that testify after me who know
more about this um section of the RSA
RSA chapter 153 cuz I mean it's a
Recovery House statute and there might
be some sections of our planning in
zoning statutes that Define it and
mention it but um or at least cite this
RSA but I'm not sure how it would be
treated under the tax law and usually
when something comes about what you know
how they would be assessed whether
commercial or residential we would
usually reach out to some assessors that
we have close connections with the ask
them how you know what what what
sections of RSA 72 the property tax uh
statutes how would this be um
interpreted how would you assess this
property so we haven't had those
conversations but I can have those and
follow up with you
further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair calls Mr Derek puka
did I get it
okay uh it's Derek
puka the G
silent um I'd like to say thank you guys
for having us here today um I am in full
support of Bill uh House Bill 432 sir
could you pull the microphone closer
we're having trouble yes can you hear me
now you
closer better okay um I'm support of
House Bill 432 um I myself am in
long-term recovery uh this past December
I celebrated five years of continuous
recovery um I'm going to talk a little
bit about my own experience within uh
recovery and in sober living as well um
I don't own a sober house I don't have
any operations and sober living um you
know I was a I've been dealing with
substance use disorder
and different various mental health
disorders since I was probably about a
teenager
um multiple treatment centers um in and
out of various incarcerations throughout
my life um starting off as a child and I
never once really felt like I belonged
anywhere until I had reached sober
living um it was something that part of
the process through my addiction I was
very hesitant towards because I always
wanted to figure it out my own way and I
also had a lot of issues with kind of
complying and abiding by various rules
and boundaries that were set forth in
front of me um in my time in sober
living um it is a very safe and
structured environment um There are
rules set forth in various you know I
know it might sound
um it might sound a little dumb if
you've never had that these sort of
learned life experiences but I never
really had any sort of structure in my
life I never really had anyone you know
necessarily like a guiding force saying
like you know um what is good and what
is not good for me
um there I learned uh a lot about myself
a lot about the addiction process and
was able to you know work myself through
the recovery process and I went from
being a resident to a house manager um
and from there I ended up becoming the
operations director for a sober living
community as well within the Manchester
area um and after that I went on to help
out with another house that had opened
up and helped you know come up with some
of the program rules and regulations and
things like that and while I can say
that there are Bad actors out there just
as there are in any line of business or
any you know facet of the world um
there's a lot of good eggs out there as
well and we just don't hear a lot about
those because they don't sell the
newspapers and the headlines and things
like that so we do hear about the bad
actors but it's all about the culture
and the community that is built within
these Sober Living homes and like that
was one thing that I really took a lot
of Pride on was the successes that
happened within the houses that I ran
and operated um up until I had reached
into sober living uh that first you know
sober living community that I was a part
of that was the longest tenure ship that
I had ever had at any place of living
since I was a child um I had been in and
out of every single apartment which
never worked out you know I I I was
struggling with every single aspect of
being a grown adult um and through the
boundaries that I had learned for myself
and the accountability and the just the
the level of community and home that I
got with within the Sober Living
Community um you know today I have a a
pretty good career within the mental
health and substance use disorder and
you know just sitting here in this in in
this courtroom I've already gotten
someone into treatment sitting back
there um it is something that I'm
extremely passionate about and I'm I'm a
huge um supporter of Sober Living homes
you know I wish it's something that I
did for myself a long time ago and
there's a lot of good that comes from it
and and again I I understand that
there's a lot of concerns about um the
the regulatory aspects of it but I think
we can all sit here and agree agree that
we have a huge housing crisis as it is
and when it comes to those that are
affected with homelessness and substance
use disorders that that that community
of itself is by and large
very very tough to to find safe secure
housing and I think that the Sober
Living Community does a really good job
and and again these success stories are
not necessarily something that we hear
about very often but they do happen um
some of my best friends that I've met in
my entire life I met as roommates in
sober living that were clean safe secure
um houses um through the work that I put
in through uh in sober living in
the the boundaries that I learned and
the things I learned about myself I'm
now a homeowner um I own a home in
Manchester I have full custody of my
children um I'm an active participant in
the recovery community and that is 100%
due to my time that I spent in sober
living in the people that were that were
able to offer that sort of housing for
people like
me um that's what I have I'm open to
questions if you guys have any thank you
for your testimony questions the chair
recognizes representative Elward thank
you madam chairman welcome to um our
committee yes thank you for having me
you you mentioned length of tenor
ship um on average how long did you
spend in each of your sit living
situations great question so I I during
my time in within the Sober Living
Community I had moved to different homes
within the program and that was solely
based on the fact that through my own
recovery process I was able
to um move within the community you know
I started as a your regular resident
there and you know through my own
accountability and recovery and helping
others I was able to move to a floor
manager position that was available in
one house because the ownership
Madame chairman may I um clarify my
question okay so this is a general yes
yes you may but General comment to
committee members is we're here to get
information with regards to the change
in the law not in particular about the
um efficacy or how recovery houses um
benefit individuals we want to zero in
on on how this new language in front of
us is going to um affect
things so yes I'm speaking to the word
non-transient in in line one um
two so this is primarily
non-transient dwelling or dwelling
unit
so approximately how long did you stay
at each of your recovery dwelling
units I had spent 19 months total within
sober
living through various moves
within within the program and moving up
um you know opportunities for leadership
positions I had moved from a different
house to another house but in totality
it was about 19 months within the Sober
Living
Community thank you further questions
seeing none thank you thank you so
much next the chair calls Mr
Adam a
aop followed by um I will call next Mr
Adam
Molton welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you very much for
having me I appreciate the time um
I'm I myself um have spent many years in
sober living um I've actually been
engaged in sober living since August
22nd of
2017 um much like the member who spoke
before me um
it's it's been the arguably the most
important part now if it had not been
available to me I would more than likely
be back in central New Hampshire up to
the same old no good that I was prior to
2017 um which then exhausts funding
based off of me being incarcerated and
taxpayers paying more money into that
effect as well um but during my stay in
long-term sober living I've been
in three separate houses about two and a
half years a piece um and just like the
member before me I have been through my
own recovery and and willingness to help
other people I've been moving up the
ladder and I now work for the operation
side of Rise Above sober living which is
one of the the larger over living groups
in in New England
um and I've had the chance to watch us
work very diligently with NH core and
get our home standardized and and
certified very quickly um I have had the
opportunity to watch countless
individuals celebrate long-term sobriety
as a direct result of the long-term care
that rise above and other sober living
alms have provided in the state um and
quite frankly I agree with everything
that was said before me I don't want to
repeat everything that they have said so
I will take questions if there are
any
questions seeing none thank
you next the chair calls Mr Adam Molton
followed by Mr
Kevin
oofin welcome to Municipal and County
government welcome thank you for having
me
I usually get yelled at for yelling so
I'm not used to having a microphone in
my
face distinguished members of the
committee today I'm representing the New
Hampshire Coalition of recovery
residences we provide critical services
including Nar certification of recovery
homes training and education on best
practices advocacy at all government
levels and mediation services for
residents our mission is to build strong
recovery communities and eliminate
barriers to recovery sportive housing
while promoting the highest standards
for New Hampshire's alcohol and
drug-free homes as someone who also
operates recovery housing I bring
firsthand experience to support NH
core's mission of expanding access to
Quality recovery housing across New
Hampshire the current regulatory laws
Place Recovery housing operators in an
unfortunate position without clear
zoning guidelines operators face a
complex series of local interpretations
that vary by
municipality some towns classify
recovery homes as boarding houses
requiring costly modifications like
sprinkler systems others impose
restrictive permitting processes that
effectively limit recovery homes to
historically underserved areas this
regulatory uncertainty creates
substantial financial and operational
risk for both ex both existing and
prospective recovery housing
operators these recovery these
regulatory barriers don't just impact
operators they create devastating
choices for people seeking recovery
right now people seeking recovery face a
tough choice they can stay near their
families and support systems without
access to recovery housing or leave
everything behind to find housing in one
of the few areas they exist this this
hits women particularly hard in the
entire northern half of our state
everything north of Laconia there are
only eight beds available for
women eight beds to serve half our state
these are mothers who can't get help
near their kids women who have to choose
between recovery and keeping their
support systems the New Hampshire
charitable Foundation research from 2017
suggests that substance use disorder
cost New Hampshire an estimated $ 2.36
billion every year even if we cut that
number in half it's still far too much
that breaks down to over $1,700 per
resident we're losing roughly 12,000
workers from our Workforce from alcohol
use disorder alone people who could be
contributing to our communities and
economy each day we wait to fix this it
costs us $6.5 million money we could be
saving through expanded access to
recovery housing right now New Hampshire
has just over, 1300 recover home beds
using a conservative estimate of 80%
capacity that's roughly 1,6 people in uh
1,46 people in recovery housing at any
given time samsa data suggests roughly
107,000 New Hampshire residents struggle
with addiction in our state the economic
impact of untreated substance use
disorder averages about 22,000 annually
per person affected remember that samsa
data was pre-co so these numbers are
likely higher now this means our current
Recovery Home save New Hampshire over
$23 million annually even at this cons
conservative
capacity and when we factor in the cost
of incarceration and recidivism with
only with over 41% of individuals
returning to prison within 3 years the
savings multiply nearly half of these
returns happen in the first year alone
recovery housing directly addresses this
by providing stable supportive
environments that reduce interactions
with criminal justice system that's just
scratching the surface of what's
possible we have the model proof that it
works and we know that for every
invested in treatment and Recovery
support we save our state about $3 in
costs the
research
um I I have more but I will uh make a
quick point about the Bad actors this
bill
specifically incentivizes people to get
certified this bill does not protect
people who are not certified AKA Bad
actors so in a lot of ways this bill is
supporting I I promise you ethically run
recovery homeowners also do not like Bad
actors we do not want them a part of
this we do not want this bill to protect
them we want those homes gone just as
much as the next
person but there are far more good
people out there who are doing really
great things and they're helping a lot
of people I'm open to any questions and
I also have the Nar standards if anybody
wants to look at them thank you
Mr Molton you had indicated on your PIN
card that you do have written testimony
do you have that for distribution for
everybody I would be happy to hand this
out because I did not do you have one
copy I do okay I'm sorry um I didn't
realize that I would beine sort that out
questions for Mr
Molton the chair recognizes
representative
France thank you madam chair and thank
you I just had a quick question about
how long does the certification process
take uh it a a lot of times depends on
the homeowner there are some homeowners
that get all their ducks in a row
quickly they get it done quickly for
instance my I was I was the first ever
certified Nar home in the state of New
Hampshire it took me roughly three
months and I have maintained
certification which we have to renew
yearly every year since then that was in
2020 thank you
but there are again homeowners who take
a long time and that can pause the
process the chair recognizes
representative Elwood thank you madam
chairman Welcome to our committee thank
you it might be in your statistics but
did you say there was a 41% recidivism
rate uh based on the doc data that I
looked up and I actually have it in my
phone I don't remember the exact year
but it is the most recent recent data
that I found it suggested
41% followup Madam chairman yes you're
saying that's from the Department of
Corrections the do correct correct so
that's it was specifically a doc
study so this was
41% of incarceration recidivism after
three years returning back to
prison and then it broke it down Year
bye percentages
across each year I'd be happy to find
the link for you if anybody is
interested okay thank you absolutely
further
questions representative majori thank
you madam chairwoman and thank you for
being here and all that you do for our
state um I'll keep coming back to this
because I'm I'm sure somebody's going to
have the answer but your perspective on
the word primarily sure in there is it
is it a necessary word does it does it
apply I'm trying to figure out why it's
why we need that word can you read the
sentence for me specifically in this
section recovery house means primarily
non-transient dwelling or dwelling unit
that provides so primarily non-transient
dwelling or dwelling unit uh that would
be a jake Barry question I did not write
this what I can tell you though is I can
answer some of the other questions
generally speaking people exist in a
recovery home for about 7 to 12 months
and that is there's obviously a spectrum
there right there are some people that
come into a recovery home and that's not
a good fit for them and they go to
another recovery home and maybe they're
there for 8 months 9 months 12 months uh
we also have levels in the recovery
homes there's level four 3 2 1 so you
have some organizations that have a true
step down process throughout I have
level one homes with individuals who
have been with me for two and a half
years and they have over two years of
recovery and they don't want to go
anywhere because they're in a congregate
living and they're with the people that
they know but in regards to why they
specifically use that verbiage I cannot
answer the question to that I'm sorry
yes further
questions seeing none um Mr Molton if
you would like there's copies of the
bill over on the side table you want to
take
one oh does anybody should I give the to
a representative kazinski and we'll get
copies for the file
wait did I
miss next the chair calls Miss anina
Hansen followed by
Erin Thor
valdson welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you I'm glad I gave you
an easy name to pronounce for once nice
and
simple good afternoon honorable chair
members of the
committee my name is anina Hansen I'm a
resident of Jaffrey and I'm here today
asking you to vote in favor of HB
432 I'm a person in recovery from
alcoholism and once upon a time I fell
in love with another New Hampshire
resident in recovery from both alcohol
and heroin addiction Phil had sobered up
in prison and when he was released he
knew he didn't stand a chance of staying
clean without a safe and supportive
place to live fortunately he found a bed
in a sober house when he needed it
it was such a life-saving measure for
him he went on to found two sober houses
of his own giving scores of people a
safe place to start again of course
recovery housing is not a magical
guarantee it's just the first step in a
long journey over time Phil started a
business bought his own home even served
as a state rep he met me and we built a
life together but then Co happened his
mental health needs went untreated and
at 5 years sober he relapsed and died of
a fentanyl overdose
until you've lost someone to overdose
you cannot fully understand the absolute
irredeemable futility of it it is a
pointless and preventable death every
single person who dies of Overdose
whether it's alcohol which is by far the
leading cause here in New Hampshire or
fentanyl or any other drug is someone
who with more time and more support
might have kicked their addiction and
built a stable life this is why a safe
environment for early recovery is Cru
crucial whenever someone's substance
dependent makes the attempt to live
substance-free the risk of relapse is
highest by far in the beginning being
surrounded by like-minded people who
offer support empathy and accountability
can be the difference between becoming a
success story or a
statistic Phil used to say my guys are
like any other group of adults who
choose to live together we are a family
by choice and we deserve the rights of a
family and certainly the rights of any
group of
housemates non-clinical recovery housing
is simply a group of men or women
choosing to split expenses by sharing a
home like lots of people do nowadays
with the added benefit that this shared
home creates lifesaving support for an
issue we're always talking about wanting
to
mitigate Phil sober houses in lonia are
still operational the guys living there
work in the labor force serve in the
community pay their taxes you've heard
lots of stories people already here
today I think I'm you know beating a
dead horse there but anyway we get the
point that sober houses produce really
good results and it's specifically
because of that early sobriety Phil
worked really hard to open sober houses
before all the requirements were in
place that are there now even more
hurdles then and he just used to
complain about why are you making it so
hard for me to help people so the point
that I want to bring here to this group
amid all you're hearing today is
just alongside the protections that are
in place whatever we do to make it easy
rather than hard and you know I think
the bad actor point was a really fair
one and I think as has been said it's
not the Bad actors that that we really
need to focus on it's all the people who
are trying so hard to do this and are
coming up against all these obstacles
from towns that are pushing back and
just a whole lot of not in my backyard
response which I get and it's fair but
it is not the whole story and it does
not bring to this how many people are
fighting for their lives and what a
relatively easy intervention it is just
to make it easy for towns to open or for
houses to open and and harder for people
to push back um in in this great big
broad Strokes
measure um yeah so anyway going back on
script now during his time in the State
House Phil sat on the Health and Human
Services committee advocating for the
needs of Grant stators in addiction and
Recovery I'm here in his place today
eight years sober to remind you that the
addict can become the public servant
when they're given the chance and the
support that all flavors of people
struggle with substance addiction and
when we ask for help we just want it to
be there when we ask for a safe place to
live we just want to know the options
are
there so there's a lot of talk about our
states addiction problems one of the
easiest answers is sober housing and
opening the way for more houses to open
rather than creating more hurdles to
those
opening that's all I have to say please
vote for 432 thank you oh actually and
if it's okay I can speak to a couple of
the questions that were raised earlier I
don't know if you want that well thank
you for your testimony and if if a
member asked ask the question got then
you can answer it thank you questions
for the
speaker okay seeing none thank you okay
thank you so next I'm G to call Mr Kevin
oofin somehow his card um hid itself for
me and got out of order so I apologize
then after that I will call Ms Aaron
Thord
Volson thank you welcome to Municipal
and County Government thank you for
having me um I'm just here to speak on
personal experience um I'm in support of
the bill and
um yeah I I'm not going to take up too
much time I uh support what some of the
previous members previous to me said um
I'm not from here I'm from Boston but I
did live in sober living for three plus
years um I recently achieved over three
years of sobriety um I now work in the
recovery field um a case manager for a
treatment center so I also have experien
helping clients transition ition from
higher levels of care down to um types
of sober living um couple things I'll
just add that I don't know if we're
brought up but um across the entire
State you know I've helped hundreds if
not thousands of people apply for sober
living um and they all have pretty tough
standards you know there's always uh
requirements that you're working a
program that you've completed some kind
of Prior treatment stabilization um
people don't just enter straight into it
um and also say that of you know moving
into the future as I hope to buy a home
someday um i' be very happy to have a
neighbor that's in a house full of
people that are actively recovering and
required to be working on themselves and
proving themselves U because I've had a
lot of Neighbors in the past that I wish
they were doing things like that so just
in the structured environment that I
experienced of being pushed to you know
work with a sponsor uh identify areas of
my life that I needed Improvement have
Community things like that um that was
just very beneficial for me and um I
believe it would honestly is the only
reason I'm sitting in front of you here
today because I did several types of
treatment throughout my uh time in
recovery and um the only missing piece
for me was the sober living you know
they say the domains of recovery or
health home community and purpose and um
you know addressed my mental health I
went to programs that every time I went
home I didn't have that safe structured
environment um that I could reintegrate
with the community with the new
behavioral skills that I was learning in
treatment so I believe that was just the
essential puzzle piece for my own
recovery um to like I said reintegrate
with the community um yeah that's that's
really all I got to add um if anyone has
questions open to it thank you for your
testimony
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair calls M eron Thor
Volson followed by Mr Jake
Barry welcome to Municipal and County
government oh thank you um I'm Aon
thalson with the Council of state
government Justice Center we are a
national nonprofit nonpartisan
organization um in support of the bill
uh so we have worked in New Hampshire
since 2021 studying and providing policy
recommendations specific to the high
utilizer population those who are
cycling between the behavioral health
and criminal justice systems and who
often have substance use disorders
mental health challenges or both the
high uer population is unique in 2024 we
found that high UTI utilizers in New
Hampshire were more likely to be
unhoused compared compared to non-high
utili utilizers we're generally admitted
to county jail or state prison for
supervision violations and were
expensive to incarcerate at a three-year
cost of $123
million such violations are often
technical in nature meaning it is not a
new crime that is bringing them back to
prison but due to behaviors such as
missing an appointment or using alcohol
or drugs we further know that time after
release can be uncertain as resources
and support may be low
we looked at the top Services asso um
accessed by individuals after release
and short-term Behavioral Health
Residential Treatment treatment for
alcohol or drugs and intensive
Outpatient Treatment were three of the
top five Services accessed House Bill
432 represents a critical step in
ensuring Equitable access to high
quality recovery housing for individuals
in recovery from substance use disorders
by incorporating clear definitions
streamlined zoning practices and
certification re requirements this
legislation aligns with best practices
outlined in the building recovery State
policy guide for supporting recovery
housing by the National Council of
Behavioral Health and promotes the
well-being of our
communities the bills updated definition
of recovery housing establishes a
foundation for highquality supportive
environments one of the Bill's most
significant Provisions is the Equitable
treatment of recovery houses in zoning
ordinances by requiring that recovery
housing be treated as single family two
family multif family residential homes
this legislation prevents undue
discrimination Federal protections under
the fair housing act and American with
Disabilities Act mandate that local
government make reasonable
accommodations for Recovery housing
ensuring that individuals in recovery
are not subject to discriminate
discriminatory housing codes or safety
standards furthermore zoning that
supports recovery housing reduces
barriers for operators and tenants to
life
as the guide highlights recovery homes
that can Market themselves as meeting
national standards demonstrate their
value and act as a strong Counterpoint
to Neighborhood concerns about locating
these homes within our communities House
Bill 432 is an important step forward in
supporting individuals in recovery
ensuring access to safe and effective
housing and protecting communities from
substandard practices the bill reflects
the best practices outlined in the
building recovery policy guide and
support our analysis at the CSG Justice
Center conducted over several years in
your state it strengthens the recovery
housing landscape Fosters long-term
recovery and aligns with federal and
state efforts to combat substance use
disorders and those who are unhoused in
our community thank you for your time
and I'll take any questions other
questions for the
speaker the chair recognizes
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman and thank you for being here
to testify this might be a dumb question
question that the gentleman behind you
who testified I probably should have
asked to but if you had a four-bedroom
home is that four residents or could it
be eight residents I'm wondering how
many people per bedroom that is
something I would not be able to speak
to Okay so thank
you representative
frock thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um one of the
previous speakers testified to a
Department of Correction
study that uh I believe he said a
43% reiv recidivism rate um of the total
Universe of people who are in substance
recovery would you have any stats on how
many are involved in the criminal
justice system versus the percentage
that are not involved with criminal
justice system that's a great question I
unfortunately don't have official stats
right at my disposal at the moment um
but we can pass along some information
on that if you could research and uh
provide that information I think the
committee would appreciate that of
course thank you yeah thank you
additional
questions representative
stavis thank you madam chair and I'm
sorry I keep asking the same question
that's okay um do sober houses typically
have paid staff
uh typically in in my experience yes and
are they classified as businesses under
New Hampshire law that I would not be
able to speak to thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you next the chair calls Mr Jake Barry
followed by Miss
um is it Luke yeah M must be Mr Luke
Castle welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair
honorable members of the committee my
name is Jake Barry uh I work for new
Futures which many of you many of you
know is a nonpartisan nonprofit Health
policy and advocacy organization we've
been working for more than 25 years to
address issues around substance use and
Behavioral Health in our state uh I
don't want to repeat too much of what's
been said obviously we stand in strong
support of the bill I do want to
reinforce a few critical points number
one I want to make sure data as referred
to earlier data is crystal clear that
neighborhoods that have access to
recovery housing experience lower rates
of substance use lower rates of other
drug related crimes lower rates of
incarceration and overall enhanced uh
not just health and well-being of
individuals but in the the neighborhoods
and the communities themselves uh
another point that I would really like
to make is that again this bill there's
been a lot of talk about Bad actors this
bill applies only to Certified Recovery
homes as has been alerted to alluded to
earlier in this hearing uh there are uh
numerous entities that in the state that
are certifying recovery homes they are
going by uh uh National national
standards uh that they are following
there are are uh 30 plus other standards
they can get into more specifically the
Govern uh the operations the physical
and and and and social well-being and
health and and safety of the uh both the
home itself and again of the the
surrounding community so this bill
really does not apply to the Bad actors
that we are discussing here um I thought
it might be helpful to provide a little
bit of background to how we got here uh
this bill originally came from a
discussion held back in the spring of
2023 we got together at the time with
our friends at the Coalition of recovery
residences the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority local planners and and
uh uh and and leaders uh to discuss ways
to support the growth of recovery
housing around the state and at the time
one of the obstacles that was identified
was a lack of clarity among cities and
towns about what exactly recovery
housing recovery houses are and how best
to treat them through local zoning and
emergency regulation after that we
worked for months uh with Town planners
the fire Marshall's office again our
friends at New Hampshire Housing and
others to craft this language what we
came up with before you uh which
clarifies that recovery houses are
residential facilities not medical
facilities as many correctly believe um
the language used is in alignment with
exist existing state fire code and
federal definitions of recovery housing
uh as I've mentioned this bill was
crafted with the assistance and of the
the planners Association the F Marshals
office other many other stakeholders it
has the strong support obviously of
recovery housing operators substance use
providers uh treatment providers housing
and homeless organizations and some in
Municipal leaders who agree will provide
uh guidance cities and towns need to
support the development of recovery
houses around the state and help them to
avoid some of the fair housing
litigation that we've seen uh filed
against cities and towns including
Manchester and nsha in recent years
um with that I am happy to take
questions the last thing I do want to
say uh you may recall this bill was
amended onto uh it passed the house with
strong bipartisan support on a voice
bill on a Voice vote last year when it
was amended onto House Bill 1521 and we
hope you will offer similar support this
year and I'm happy to take
questions other questions for Mr
Barry representative frock thank you
madam chair uh Mr
Barry the language of the bill States on
line 16 and
17 um the operator shall be actively
pursuing
certification and Achieve certification
within one year after beginning
operations um how would that be in en
forced who is the enforcer who
determines how how does it work sure
again we have certifying entities in the
state who are who are out there
conducting certification inspections and
making sure you know and and issuing the
certifications themselves uh they
certainly I'm sure and again they're in
the room they can work but I'm they
frequently work with municipalities I
think who would um uh you know be able
to again check on the status and I will
say the reason that we settled on one
year you know we want to make sure that
we are are meaning the B balance of
providing homes the time they need to
complete the certification process and
they really in many cases need to be up
and running in order to go through that
certification process so we want to make
sure that they have enough time to get
off the ground uh in order to uh again
demonstrate that they meet those
certification standards so we wanted to
make sure that we provided uh enough
time to do that without so much time
that they were able to um abuse any any
lapses or or anything like
that yes and in the event that year they
do not meet certification what happens
oh at that point you know local
Regulators local zoning officials are
able to step in the way that they are
and you know the same if um uh you know
the same way they enforce any other
zoning C zoning codes
locally
sure representative
grund thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um in here
it's line 14 and 15 where it talks about
the use of an existing multif family
structure as a recovery house under this
paragraph shall not require site plan
review we heard a concern that is there
um you know health safety concerns can
you speak to um the process of being
certified do they look at building the
site plan concept do they work through
that to make sure there aren't any other
safety concerns again there's certainly
others in the room who work more work in
a day-to-day way more in in the
certification process who can speak to
that certainly again many of the
certification standards do govern many
of the same um health and and Welfare uh
uh areas that are governed in in in um
by by site plan review uh and again I do
want to be crystal clear that that these
houses will be absolutely held to the
same zoning requirements and regulations
as any other uh you know as any other
multif family or similarly you uh use
building that is in fact at the root of
the very intention of the bill is to
ensure that that that these houses are
held to the same standard as any other
multif family or M multi-unit structure
and and not beyond that again as is
restricted by by federal fair housing
regulations the chair recognizes
representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question it has to do
with uh fire codes sure um and to the
best of my recollection in
2018 we revised F A we passed a bill
that revised the fire code to require
sprinklers in these
facilities
um sprinklers municipalities are
prohibited from requiring sprinklers in
single family houses and
duplexes how do those two things mesh in
your mind sure no no that with with with
the zoning language in this bill that
that's a fantastic question and and
again I want to be clear I'm not I'm not
a building professional I'm not an
enforcement professional um I you know
we did work on I recall the bill you're
talking about there was another bill
that we worked on a number of years ago
that passed that sort of clarified the
um process of I'm I'm blanking on the
formal term the process of seeking an
exemption from um from the fire
Marshall's office uh in in in these
cases
um I'm not sure I can answer the
question as as as articul articulately
as I would like uh I think the again the
the the clear thing to keep in mind I
would say is these facilities are held
to the same fire and safety codes as any
other multi-use facility that you know
that is used the uh um that that has as
multiple families and they they um yes
uh they will be held to the same
standards nothing all we're asking for
is nothing
Beyond representative
Elward thank you madam chairman thank
you for taking my question on line 18
uses the word
operator the its operator shall first
provide written notification to the
local governing body at least 30 days
prior to and on line 20 it says the
local governing body May seek to ensure
that the recovery house is either
certified or seeking certification would
it not be the operator who is seeking
certification and not the the recovery
house
house certainly I see I I I see clearly
what you're pointing out here and I
think that that does seem to be an
inconsistency in the language that I'm
certain that we could iron out for sure
and I have a follow-up question
sure if the operator is
the
uh certificate holder
MH are they also the homeowner the
building owner
and if
so would this not be like a home
occupation so in some cases and again
there others in the room can speak to
this better than who have more firsthand
experience in this than I do in some
cases they are the owner operator in
some cases they're not they they they
you know lease or rent or manage the
property say that again please I'm sorry
in some cases they are the owner
operator of the building they they own
the building as well as op as operate in
other cases they uh they you know it's
it's run by you know they they rent it
or lease it or or or have a property
management uh uh Arrangement just as any
other multif family uh uh
operation thank you further
questions representative
Gerard thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um you mentioned
that the home needed to be up and
running prior to applying for
certification is there a certain
standard that you have to meet to be
able to start applying is there a
certain number of uh folks that would
need to be in the home what is the
process I I thank you for the question
represented I would love to defer to
some of the operators in here who can
speak to it more directly than than I
can thank
you additional
questions seeing none thank you thank
you the chair calls Mr Luke Hassel
followed by Mr Chris shut or shot
welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you your honorable
chair thank you for having me and
members of the municipal and County
government committee my name is Luke
Hassel I'm going to speak to my own
experience um being around the
recovery atmosphere recovery homes and
also working in the field and being in
recovery myself um I'm a resident of
Bosco in New Hampshire I'm testifying
today to urge you to support HP 432
relative to the development of recovery
housing my journey in recovery began 616
2019 at the homestead in bosow in New
Hampshire when I got to the homestead I
was a month off drugs and alcohol
extremely angry with not much personal
belongings and a general disr of every
kind mentally emotionally physically and
spiritually the homestead in was a vital
part and provided stability during my
recovery Journey when I could surround
myself where I could surround myself
with like-minded peers going through
similar experiences during my time spent
at the homestead in I regained
employment working in construction in
Manchester New Hampshire became a
productive working member of society and
I owe my growth and change to be a
productive member of society to the
homestead its owner Christine pette her
family the three dogs and the four
goats it was intrical um
all of the residents that have come
there since when when I got there uh as
well as my recovery program sponsors and
a higher power I would hate to think of
where I'd be if I didn't have all of
that
support four key points before I wrap up
New Hampshire Corp has been certifying
home since its Inception in 2019 by
national
standards intrical part in getting these
homes certified since I've been around
the area the average success rate to my
uh research for an average stay of 9 to
18 months at a sober house is
60% all of the sober home owners and
managers that I know are responsible
ethical and caring they provide
structure for residents access to
recovery meetings Health Care Counseling
community service work employment and
education furthermore drug cour
probation and parole support and see the
benefits of sober houses in the commun
community and finally the last point I
am not ignorant to the fact that there
may be very well concerns about this
demographic that being said thoughtful
minds and Caring Hearts with that in
mind everyone's concerns can be
addressed I believe this and again I
urge you to vote in favor of HB 4032 432
if pass this bill can greatly benefit
the recovery community so that they can
have a successful inov an experience in
the recovery Journey as I have thank you
for your time and consideration I'm
happy to answer questions other
questions for the
speaker seeing N I do have a question
with regards to the um certification
that's been mentioned and a lot of
recovery homes um seek to meet the
requirements of the national standards
of certification could you speak to if
you know if that certification um
encompasses capacity of of a residence
there was a question that was asked with
regards to well what if this residence
has four bedrooms does the
certification national standards speak
to that in that four bedrooms would mean
uh four residents or would that mean two
to three persons per bedroom can you
help to understand that unfortunately
honorable chair I cannot I do not have
that knowledge or experience that's okay
thank
you additional
questions seeing thank you for your
testimony next the chair calls Mr Chris
is it sh shot shot shot good and then
following will be Mr Matthew
plus welcome to Municipal and County
government you good afternoon members of
the committee my name is Chris shot and
I'm the fair housing director at New
Hampshire legal assistance I'm here
today to speak in favor of HP 432 a bill
that clarifies how recovery houses will
be treated for zoning purposes plenty of
our clients at nhla have been aided by
the services of recovery houses in
supporting their Journey out of
addiction and in independent living and
long-term recovery beyond the benefits
that recovery housing has for some of
our clients what I specifically want to
address in my testimony today is my
support for the bill is that uh is the
benefits that I believe municipalities
will receive by avoiding Fair Housing
Act litigation over zoning decisions
regarding recovery
homes one of the more common areas of
fair housing litigation is in regard to
recovery homes the Fair Housing Act
prohibits discrimination in housing
based on race color na religion sex
national origin familial status and
disability while many think of the
rental and sale of housing as the
traditional subject area where the Fair
Housing Act comes into play it also
applies to other actions and actors that
touch on housing such as Municipal
zoning boards in fact one of the main
motivations in passing the Fair Housing
Act was to end discriminatory zoning
policies throughout the act's history
Recovery Home sighting has been a
subject of fair housing litigation
primarily dealing with efforts by
municipalities to use their zoning
powers to restrict their operation
substance abuse disorder is a disability
under the fair housing act and as such
recovery homes are protected by the fair
housing act based upon disability status
of the clients they
serve HP 432 is intended to clarify the
zoning process in order to eliminate
confusion and prevent actions Municipal
zoning boards that may lead to costly
Fair Housing Act lawsuits this bill
would um specify how a recovery house is
zoned preventing potential unintended
zoning actions that may implicate
implicate the fair housing act in New
Hampshire alone there have been multiple
lawsuites brought in the past few years
against municipalities who have used
their zoning powers to restrict recovery
um uh Recovery Home Development
specifically in Asha and Manchester
while I'm in no way an expert in the
specific area of fair housing litigation
and as such not aware of every single
challenge or issue in the region I am
also aware that municipalities and other
states we border face the same issues
Fitchburg and Wester u m in
Massachusetts were subject to
significant litigation in 2019 and 2021
that led to development of case law on
the issue here in the first
circuit the presence of a lawsuit does
not necessarily mean that a municipality
has used its zoning power improperly or
in a discriminatory manner however even
when a municipality prevails in a
lawsuit the damage may already be done
recovery homes necessary to support
residents of the state are denied
leaving those seeking recovery with no
good options towns further face costly
litigation that drains its time and
resources with the expiration of federal
um funding for um during from during the
co pandemic funds uh many municipalities
are facing tighter budgets that may be
dramatically impacted by litigation
costs which may require higher taxes or
challenging decisions on cutting
services this in turn is passed on to
taxpayers who may bear the cost of
higher taxes for zoning decisions they
were not involved with and did not
support by clarifying how Recovery House
houses are zoned I believe that HP 432
will help increase Recovery Home apply
eliminate confusion that Municipal
zoning boards May face when considering
recovery homes and avoid potentially
costly litigation expenses I ask the
committee to support HP 432 and welcome
any questions that I might be able to
answer thank you for your
time
questions the chair recognizes
representative Gilman for a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question
um I I'm curious about the phrase in
where I marked it up um the use of an
existing this is lines 14 and 15 the use
of an existing multif family structure
as recovery house under this paragraph
shall not require site plan review and
given the the nature of the purpose of
the recovery houses that gather folks
from separately not in a family why why
is the the multif family one uh not
require site plan review but the single
family it you
know shouldn't the single family also be
or maybe I just answer my
question yeah and I do apologize for
anything drafting related to this I will
refer to Mr Barry which I know was a
common refrain today but thank you yes
okay never mind representative stavis
I'm sorry I'm going to sound like a
broken record but I'm I'm still trying
to get an answer to the question of
whether the recovery
houses as defined in this bill are
businesses are they
nonprofits uh what is their
taxable standing what you know how are
they defined under taxation laws I
believe it depends on the specific um
recovery home but again that's not my
area of expertise I would refer it to Mr
Barry I think he'll be able to
answer further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so I'm down to two pink cards and
the chair calls Mr Matthew plush
followed by Mr Jonathan garon
thank you welcome to Municipal and
County government thank you um I'm
Matthew plat I live in wolfboro I am the
executive director at White Horse
recovery uh we're a nonprofit that was
started 10 years ago to uh deal with to
fight this epidemic of
opioids uh we have 28 employees now we
most are in recovery themselves we have
csws we have we provide Clinical
Services we have mlx and
lcsws we operate four of the state's 20
recovery Community organizations uh they
are walk-in
centers that provide services to people
in
addiction uh anything from getting them
into detox when they're ready or
providing pure
support uh showers laundry if they need
it many of many of our clients live in
the woods many uh we have a lot of
homelessness for people people that are
suffer suffering from sud very often are
homeless
now uh we've had a lot of testimony
about the benefits of recovery housing I
can tell you it's it's far and way the
biggest problem we're dealing with uh in
helping people suffering from sud in LW
long-term
addiction housing is a major problem if
we can get people into a secure stable
housing environment we can M they are
much more successful in sustaining their
recovery uh they get and they get back
into the workforce they get back with
their families and we're looking
at uh 9 months to two years in sober
living or longer if if the situation
fits uh I don't see sober living is a
transient place we call them it's
they're now called recovery
housing the um the issue here as I see
it is we have towns treating recovery
houses in in different ways uh I'm
trying to open one right now I'm not
going to name the town but I've been
told I have to do site plan I have to do
uh uh go through planning go through uh
planning
review it's a single family home that uh
I'm not changing the size of the house
uh I'm complying with the standards uh
for Recovery housing uh national
standards which
are uh in terms of how many people per
bedroom I I need at least 50 square feet
per bed so I can put two people in a
bedroom uh
we will have very strict requirements
for drug
testing uh very strict requirements um
require uh for uh Counseling Group
attendance to group meetings U and it's
a very supportive
environment people living as a single
family um the under fact federal law as
you just
heard if you treat people if you treat
this kind of housing differently from a
normal single family house there's a
potential for litigation I'm not
litigious I'm not going to be filing
lawsuits against the town it's not what
I want to do but it can happen and this
bill it this bill
um provides towns the benefit of not
running a f
of federal law on this and I can read
you um this is under the fair housing
act when it was passed in enacting
protections for persons with
disabilities a specific concern was in
this this is a
quote imposition of health safety or
land use requirements on congregate
living arrange Arrangements among
non-related persons with
disabilities that were not imposed on
families and groups of similar size or
of other unrelated
people under the Americans with
Disabilities Act and this is another
quote from the right from the statute no
qualified individual with a disability
shall by reason of such disability be
excluded from participation in or or be
denied the benefits of the services
programs or activities of of a public
entity or be subjected to discrimination
by such entities
so when you treat recovery homes
differently from a a single family
home you open yourself up to be ued
under these two
statutes so I'm happy to take
questions the chair re Rec recognizes
rep representative major thank you madam
chairwoman thank you for taking my
question if you were to if one of of
your houses were to require a or had a
failed septic system how would
Dees how would
Dees evaluate the size the proper sizing
of the septic
system do you know the answer to that I
do not okay
thanks representative majority I I
believe I know the answer and the answer
is that the septic system is sized to
the um to to to to the house to the
number of of bedrooms and not occupants
correct and and that's where I wonder if
de I wonder if May question of the
chair is that something we could follow
up with on Dees with Dees I think you
just volunteered to do that I
[Laughter]
did okay how you do it I'll do
it representative Grant
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question um I'm going to ask
the question I did before because maybe
you're able to answer this but um on
line 145 where it says use of an
existing multif family structures
recovery house under this paragraph
shall not require a site plan review
during the certification process of a
program for Recovery Home Does it
include steps that are similar to a site
plan review uh there's a lot of detail
that goes in well I would say no I mean
site planner view is if you're changing
the site so I would say no but there's a
lot that goes into how you're running
the house the rules inside the house the
size requirements for
bedrooms
um you're you have to have one shower
for every six residences one bathroom
for every six residents
so further
questions seeing none thank oh sorry
representative Gerard thank you madam
chair uh I'm hoping you might be able to
answer the question I had asked another
person earlier uh I think when you
started talking about the certification
process that someone mentioned that they
had to be up and running to be able to
apply for certification is there a
certain standard as far as how how
much how many people need to be in
the environment before they can apply
for
certification I don't know if there is
um I would expect it would take two to
three months to you know bring people
into the house once you're up and
running you can't get certified until
you are up and
running uh but again this a lot of the
certification requirements go to the
rules for running the house um there has
to be zero drugs zero you know zero use
of drugs or alcohol in the house that's
one of the
requirements uh so the this this concern
about you know we're going to have
people and it's the nimi concern we
don't want that we don't want addicts
living on our road well these aren't
people in addiction these are people in
recovery
so thank
you additional
questions okay seeing none thank
you so my final pin card here is Mr
Jonathan Garrison welcome to Municipal
and County Government
thank you madam chair uh and committee
members
um uh forgive me I don't like public
speaking but I'm very passionate about
this particular bill in this uh and this
issue as a whole um I'm um someone in
recovery uh got sober in
2016 uh I'm a licensed realtor in the
state of New Hampshire uh I also am the
owner of recovery residences in New
Hampshire I'm also on the board of
directors of the New Hampshire Coalition
of recovery
residences uh I have been throughout
this state um in front of many planning
boards and in front of many zoning
boards I've experienced the
nimbyism that has risen to the level of
discriminatory I have seen many planning
and zoning boards looking for a solution
and I see this bill as a solution
um what I see in this
bill
underlines 15 and 16 we identify a body
we identify a certification body that
knows what a safe ethically run recovery
residence should look like that's one
party I see in line 18 and 19 it
identifies a municipality that we have
to provide notice to and in line 20 and
21 I see a a State Fire Marshal and
local fire marshall that will also uh
get notice so I see three parties plus
the recovery residents I see all four
important stakeholders working
together that has not been happening to
date I see this bill bringing all
stakeholders together to make sure that
a house uh is known and the house is
running safely and
ethically
um I also see it clearly defining it uh
a recovery house is non-transient in a
residential use I know the question has
come up whether it's a business I'm not
a tax attorney um I file a business tax
return um but the way the within the
home
itself uh the people living within the
home there's no business being done
within the home it's a residential
use
uh happy to answer any questions that
anybody
has thank you for your testimony you did
excellent thank you the chair recognizes
representative Gerard thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question you just mentioned that the
fire marshal are you stating that you
believe the way the bill is written or
the the prop suppose is written that the
Fire Marshall and fire codes would have
to be met even before you after you give
you 30-day notice before anybody could
go in
there uh yes I do thank
you further
questions the chair recognizes
representative Gilman thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question um hopefully I'll be more
articulate with this one um in your
experience of uh owning and running
um recovery houses have you had
resistance to a single family house
being turned into a or being changed to
a recovery house yes I have
okay and that
followup yes um have you been uh pushed
out basically or refused I have not okay
thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you so that was my the last pink that
was the last pink card that we had so I
will ask is there anyone present who
wishes to speak to the bill who has not
yet had the opportunity to do
so seeing none the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report the blue
sheets thank you madam chair uh the
onine line presence is uh support uh vot
in 110 in opposition was six and the
paper blue sheet with support two and
opposition
one thank you repres representative
Gilman and with that I will close the
public hearing on House Bill 432
people a second to
yeah that's kind that was the biggest
thing to mind
okay everybody at this time I'm going to
begin the hearing on the last publicly
noticed bill for this committee for
today it was to begin at 1:20 and I do
apologize to the prime sponsor the
previous um Bill public hearing
obviously went quite
long
so at this time I would like to open the
public hearing on House Bill
447 relative to property tax exemptions
for disabled
veterans the chair recognizes
representative kraton the prime sponsor
of the bill to introduce it to the
committee welcome to Municipal and
County government thank you madam chair
and thank you all for your patience I
appreciate your detailed discussion and
uh I look forward to answering your
questions HB 447 is
um it's based on an update to RSA 72
colon
36a and essentially uh we passed a law
that said that disabled veterans were
authorized to attack exemption at the
local level and that law is currently in
place what we have found though is that
there's a category of disabled veterans
that are excluded from this law and
essentially those excluded are excluded
because that the VA had had made changes
to their houses and and it just
technically didn't fit in and so what
we've done is we've added those disabled
veterans who are approved disabled
veterans through the normal process
that's already in law and we've this law
this bill would uh allow them the
disabled veterans tax exemption that is
already in existence so we don't change
the disability requirements we don't
change the uh the rules associated with
administering this law all we do is say
that there are disabled veterans that
are currently excluded and now we
include them subject to any questions
that's my testimony Madam questions for
representative
kraton representative Gilman thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
for taking my question
if I understand you
correctly the problem that this is
fixing is uh this the loan or tax
exemption
for things that have been provided by
the Veterans
Administration as opposed
to things that have been modified
because the
hospital the VA Hospital require or has
recommended or requires that you have
this help exactly and and in the bottom
line it's the same situation it's just
about who fixed the house okay thank you
and we're adding adding the other one in
there good question thank you ma'am
further
questions I have a few questions yes
ma'am so um just to clarify on lines
seven and eight the the amended or added
languages or owns a home that is ADA
Compliant and meets the needs of their
disability
yes ma'am so does that imply that a
veteran could um install a ramp at their
residents because they are Mo they have
mobility
issues it does but they would also have
they have that disabled veteran has to
qualify under the current law so it
doesn't change the qualification and so
if that disability requires a ramp then
yes that ramp could be added to the
house could you clarify that I'm I'm
conf because you're saying could you
specifically point to what the
qualifications are under this um section
of yes ma'am it's under statute RSA 72
colon
295 and it's not written on the it's not
written on the
bill you see the colon at the end at the
bottom there that's where it leads to
those exact qualifications um
my understanding with the reference to
7229 V would be the definition of a
surviving
spouse is is that
incorrect
uh yeah okay fair
enough the eligibility for the veteran
is in RSA 21 colon
50 on the top
line okay
and okay I I will continue um I have a a
followup question please are you aware
of when this particular statute certain
disabled veterans when was it last
changed I I don't know
ma'am okay that the answer would be last
year
okay
yeah okay but but the the issue remains
that
um regardless of what it came into being
there is a category of veterans that are
that are excluded that should be
included so the last thing that that I
will add is that this um this this
certain disabled veterans the section of
Statute was there was a bill that
changed this law last year for the
purposes of specifically clarifying who
qualifies just to be clear yes
ma'am further
questions representative
Colby thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um Dr provided
the committee um with a 2024 exemption
numbers a few weeks
ago and under the RSA is currently
written there is about 39 million in
Grants um you have an estimate on if we
do widen that net to include um homes
that are ADA Compliant uh or modified
through the VA system um what the
financial impacts would be or how many
more veterans would be qualifying no
ma'am I
don't further
questions seeing none thank you
representative kraton thank you I
appreciate it and I do have to depart I
have a meeting I'm headed too so thank
you so much y thank you
so next the chair recognizes uh
representative John
sudor welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair sorry
everybody I'm fighting a sinus issue
that's making me talk a little bit rough
uh if I may address this you asked about
the ramp issue uh if you go could you
just hold so first we need you to um
state your name who you represent and um
your disposition on the bill and then
provide testimony okay my name is John
suder um District 36 represent Mason
Brooklyn and uh uh Greenville
and I approve I I really hope we can
approve having this moved the question
was asked on a last testimony about the
ramps
in the last 20 to 30 years
houses throughout the state throughout
the United States have had a lot of ADA
Compliant things done it's currently in
most building standards anymore so it's
a possible for a person to actually use
their VA loan to go out and buy a house
that already has some ADA Compliant
issues in there now it does it meet all
their requirements that they need for
the disability it may it may not but
then the VA through the Prosthetics
clinic will come out through the primary
care provider recommendation and do an
evaluation of that home they will come
physically look at the home and they
will turn around and uh talk with the
veteran and they will make
recommendations how to make it ADA
Compliant for that specific injury that
the veteran has they will go out and
hire a contractor the VA will they will
have the contractor come out and provide
provide
whatever um structure that needs to be
changed on the home it's documented it's
who's did it when he did it what time it
was approved what date all the way down
to what time of the day that they showed
up and did the inspection and the day
they did the modifications to the
home so when the question was asked
earlier to me about well how does the
assessor know about this it's easy when
the veteran applies for this that letter
to the VA says we did this to your home
and this is what it's the modifications
that we did to your bathroom or your
kitchen or whatever the case may be that
is provided by the veteran to the
selectman which I am a selectman of my
town and that's how why I brought this
up because all that information is given
to us so we can provide it to the
assessor so there is no question that
yes a ADA Compliant bathroom has been
put in a special lift has been put into
a bathroom a bedlift has been put into a
bedroom whatever case that that veteran
has but working with my Our Town
assessor because it was new from last
year I believe June or July of last year
we wanted to make sure we're doing
correct by our veterans so we asked our
assessor what do we do here we don't
know we want to make sure we're doing
this correctly our assessor went and
talked to Mr William Gad which is the
New Hampshire Department of Veterans
Affairs
director to get a his input we want to
make sure we're doing correct
and they come back and said well if they
don't have the representative sudor yes
ma'am you're just about
to State publicly something that
somebody else said that would be hearsay
so I have writing well you you're not
saying that okay but I would prefer that
you would stick to what you know okay
yes ma'am and that is your testimony
okay so as the bill is written now
if a veteran does not have an sah
specific
Grant or an sh specific Grant which are
made to either build or modify the home
the veteran no matter how injured they
are no matter how bad they are their
condition they do not qualify to get
this because they don't have those two
grants because they're specifically
named as that's what's qualifies so
we've forgotten the injury we forgotten
everything that medically that person
has a have when we've tied it to two
grants when there's actually other
grants out there and the VA Hospital
does this as well so if we add this
lettering in there all it shows is that
a veteran who may be combined to a chair
cannot walk maybe paraplegic maybe
whatever the case may be God bless
them that the VA has come out and modify
their homes as well the medical doesn't
change nothing changes in the law all
this is doing is just saying
we paid out of a different pot for the
same
modifications any
questions questions for representative
suder hope I said it right see seeing
none I I do have a question so I asked
the prime sponsor and so I just want to
understand is it possible that a veteran
who has mobility issues and needs
assistance with say a cane
um has a ramp installed in in at their
residence I it's a two-part question and
so the ramp uh would meet the needs of
their disability who assesses that this
particular ramp is meeting that need
that that is number one so just answer
maybe you can answer that and then I'll
follow up again when the primary care
physician represents this to the
Prosthetics Clinic at the VA Hospital
right here in Manchester they sent a
technician out the technician has a list
of all your
disabilities the technician will go over
your home and see what you need in order
to make that home livable for you if
they determine that's a ramp is needed
they will specifically say why the ramp
is needed it's not just oh we wanted to
put a ramp on our house cuz he walk was
a cane specifically why it has to be
there it has to be documented once
that's documented then it's sent back to
the Prosthetics Clinic
they sign off on it and they hire a
contractor to come out and stall the
ramp inside or outside of the
house okay so my my second question
would be with regards to to you know
this
veteran having an ADA Compliant ramp
installed to meet their needs is it
possible that this particular
individual is full is fully employed no
the medical requirements stays the same
they have to be 100% disabled
unemployable that does not change they
have to be these are people who can't
work these aren't people that are you
know a disabled veteran that got bad
knees from falling out of airplanes like
I did for too many years these are
people that are you know severely
injured so it it they have that the
medical requirements that's already in
law does not change
further
questions seeing none thank you thank
you and the the final pink card for this
bill is from M Melinda Sims so the chair
calls M
Sims welcome to to Municipal and County
government that to this gentleman here
please thank you
all and I'm a a disabled veteran uh
total impermanent
100% and tdiu which means
unemployable uh from a spinal cord
injury that I incurred in the military
I'm also um the advocacy coordinator for
United spinal Association uh New
Hampshire chapter and we are an advocacy
a grassroot advocacy group that works on
issues like um accessible housing
parking transportation
emergency process so on I'm speaking to
you today about HB 447 relative to
property tax exemption for disabled
veterans I'm opposed to this because um
while I strongly support tax relief for
disabled veterans I have identified
several technical concerns with the
Bill's current language that requires
your attention the current law RSA 7236
a requires veterans to meet two specific
specific criteria for this tax one is to
have a qualifying severe disability
which is 100% total disability be a
double ampute paraplegic or have a
service connected blindness rating and
have a home modified through the VA
special adapted housing SA or special
home adapted grants sha or purchased
using proceeds from selling such
modified home the proposed bill would
add two new ways to qualify having an
ADA Compliant home or a modified through
the VA hospital system this creates
several
concerns the reference to VA Hospital
System modification appears to mean hisa
Grant
hisa uh I I gave you all a really nice
packet that explains a lot of this um
however hisa grants have very different
requirements they're available to
Veterans with disability ratings as low
as
50% and can be used for non-service
conditions this is substantially
different from the current requirements
of 100% permanent and total
disability here's a critical scenario to
consider under title 38 USC chapter 21
veterans with severe disabilities like
loss of both lower extremities blindness
plus loss of one lower extremity or
other qualifying conditions are eligible
for Sasha grants however some of these
veterans may not need such extensive
modifications their service connected
disabilities might be better served by
simpler ADA compliance measures or hisa
modifications under the current law
these veterans despite having
disabilities severe enough to qualify
for Sasha grants would not qu qualify
for the tax exemption simply because
they chose more appropriate less
extensive modifications for their
specific needs for example a veteran who
has lost both lower extremities and
qualifies for some might only need a
wheelchair ramp and a bathroom
modification rather than the
comprehensive structural changes by
Sasha grants despite having a qualifying
severe disability if they don't use the
Sasha Grant program they cannot get the
tax exemption under the current law even
though they have the same level of
disability as someone who does not use
the Sasha M so what I'm recommending is
maintaining the current severe
disability qualification
requirements expanding the modification
options to include ADA compliance or
hisa grants but only to Veterans who
first meet the severe disability
requirements that would qualify them for
the Sasha Grant so this current bill
would would not specify that and it
needs to be requiring proof that the
modifications add address their service
connected disability needs so meaning um
Physical Therapy coming out and
addressing so as currently written I
cannot support HB 447 due to the
technical issues I've outlined
however if amended to maintain the
current disability thresholds while
allowing additional modification options
for those who meet the stri these strict
requirements I would fully support this
legislation such changes would preserve
the original intent of supporting our
most severely disabled veterans while
giving them more flexibility to choose
modifications the best suits their P
specific needs thank you for your time
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony Miss Sims
representative
Elward thank you madam chairman good
afternoon good do you have suggested
language to accomplish your or address
your
concerns I would I would
highlight
um well
in oops let me get back to my page good
question
I think I would put the the
recommendations that I have like where
it says that the person would need to
meet the the rag
38 um the
CR uh here it is 38 USC chapter 21 they
would need to meet that and be able to
um be eligible for the Sasha grants uh
there
is information here that tells about the
Sasha Grant in the form that they would
need to complete so if they would
complete that form and show eligibility
and you can get that right off of their
eligibility letter so if they can prove
that that they are eligible for the
Sasha then that also proves that of
their 100% total and permanent tvu
answer to a additional questions a
followup
quickly that was very confusing to me as
a lay person so if if you could suggest
actual legislative language absolutely I
um and send it the committee that would
be helpful thank you absolutely thank
you further
questions I had a did I see a hand over
there no so I do I have a quick question
so you you were one of your suggested
revisions was um had to do with to an
applicant should be able to be eligible
for the SAA s or sha grants is it true
that in for for any
Grant in order to determine eligibility
then an an individual would have to fill
out the application provide supporting
documentation and then that Grant in
that application would need to be
evaluated by some party to determine El
eligibility absolutely so that they have
to be first off they have to meet the 38
uh CFR reg um 100 no I I'm going to
interject I understand that my point is
is it's unclear as to who would um
evaluate the application so while it's
in it's it's a it's a little deficient
just my point I don't know
who this is an RSA
so I don't know who would determine the
eligibility based on your suggestion so
there is a determining body for the
Sasha Grant they are they are a specific
body for that the applicant fills out
the application puts it in and then they
will determine whether the person is is
eligible eligible for that or not as far
as uh like if they need a ramp or
something in the home that's all through
PT like uh representative sudder had
suggested did that answer your question
yes it does thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you
all we had one additional pink card
manifest and that was from Mr Brody Dees
welcome back to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chairwoman
and uh thank you to the committee I'll
be extremely brief um we were contacted
by a few assessors that had concerns and
some of their concerns were actually
raised today by members of the committee
and that is um how exactly to keep track
of these um these upgrades or different
changes to the dwellings or to the homes
to the residential homes um to keep
track of you know for this tax exemption
and um we think just a slight
modification to the existing statute uh
specifically 72 colon
36-a Roman 2 where it says satisfactory
proof of such service connection
disability is furnished to the assessors
if just at and that's not in the bill
that's in the statute it's the section
there's a Roman one and a Roman two
below the um what is currently being
modified in the bill and um we think if
if it was more clear what would be
provided to the assessors to verify um
that the uh that the specific um ADA
Compliant and meets the needs of the
disability or modifications from the VA
hospital system that there might be a
way to work with um the Veterans Affairs
folks and other uh stakeholders be able
to find out what is the best paperwork
that assessors should be requesting so
they can verify um this you know they
can verify for the tax exemption statute
and um I'll answer any questions but I
imagine you guys want to get to
Executive session so questions for Mr
Dees seeing none thank
you my final question to the audience on
the final bill is there anyone present
who wishes to speak on the bill who has
not yet had the opportunity to do
so seeing none the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report out the
blue sheets thank you madam chair uh on
the remote sign in there were uh 10
votes in support and zero in opposition
on today's blue sheet there were two in
support and zero in
opposition thank you and with that the
public hearing
on House Bill 447 is now
closed so that ends our publicly noticed
hearings for today in a moment we will
transition into executive
session
e
e e
so next the committee is going to move
into executive session we were
tentatively scheduled to commence this
um uh around two and we are behind I
would like to
um notify the committee that
we we need to
ideally complete our work here by 5:00
p.m if we do need to extend beyond 5:00
pm I'm going to need to take a short
break and I need to c contact house
committee services so they can do what
they need to do because that would be
after hours for for the staff so just
keep that in mind if at all
possible representative Murphy
would you be better off asking for
permission
now
no that they're they're watching so
they're somebody's watching so they're
seeing how long this is taking
so
yeah the reason I said that I probably
didn't say it very very well but you
know when we're getting close to five
they'll be somewhat aware but I need to
contact them to specifically um indicate
that so I'm just giving the clerk some
time to get organized and then then
we'll
start for
at this time at this time I will open
the executive session on House Bill 139
relative to the official designation of
holidays by municipalities and
educational institutions
no
just
well the chair recognizes um
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman I would like to move itl on
House Bill 139 and if it seconded I'll
be happy to speak to my motion I will I
will second that motion thank you
representative stavis seconds itl
representative majori would you like to
speak to your motion thank you madam
chairwoman yes um uh one of the main
object well it's not really an objection
to this bill we recognize that state
statute uh pulls out the major holidays
for the state there's nothing that says
you cannot add um to the title of any
one of these in any of your Publications
as long as you have the major holidays
listed in that publication so there's no
reason why you can't say that Columbus
Day could also be indigenous people day
and for those reasons since you there's
no prohibition on adding uh we don't see
why this bill is
necessary
discussion seeing none um
we'll move to a vote the motion before
us is inexpedient to legislate on House
Bill
139 if you support the motion then you
will vote Yes if you oppose the motion
then you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chair McDonald
yes Vice J McDonald votes
yes representative
Guthrie
yes representative Guth three votes
yes representative Dolan
yes representative Dolan votes
yes representative award yes
representative Elward votes
yes the clerk votes
yes representative
France representative France votes
yes represent representative karasinski
yes representative Kosinski votes yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Murphy votes yes
representative Walker yes representative
Walker votes yes representative stavis
yes representative stavis votes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Gilman votes
yes repe representative majori yes
representative majority vote Yes
representative frock yes representative
frock vot votes yes representative Colby
yes representative Colby votes yes
representative gerana yes representative
gerana votes
yes representative Gerard
yes representative Gerard votes yes
representative grund yes representative
grund votes
yes chairman power yes chairman power
votes
yes um 11 I
think the vote is unanimous at 18 to0
the committee recommendation on how post
Bill
139 is inexpedient to legislate without
objection the recommendation will go on
to the house consent calendar and the
committee report will be written
by representative majority thank
you with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill 139
next I will open the executive session
on House Bill 346 FN relative to The
Lure fees for
racetracks I'll make a motion to accept
that as printed um the chair recognizes
representative Murphy for a
motion and what was your motion to
accept it as printed
printed OTP could you yes so your motion
is ought to pass ought to pass okay I'm
sorry get a little bit moderated mode
that's okay is is there a second
uh representative kazinski seconds the
motion second
discussion sorry would you like to speak
to your motion to representative Murphy
yes all this does it right now it's $100
it can go up to um up to 500 but it's a
May doesn't have to if if a town wants
to it could be a dollar
further discussion representative Gerard
thank you madam chair um I respect the
thoughts of the representative that just
spoke this appears to be one community
that has this issue uh as we know we had
one community that did show up and if
you look at the irsa the way it's
currently written uh the it talks about
making the bylaws relating to Regulation
and Licensing the motor vehicle
racetracks and this was done as a
one-time thing ahead of time where which
is why the racetrack that was here last
week spoke that they basically every
year um they know that they're going to
have so many dates so many hours they
can
operate the $100 is basically for the
annual operation of the racetrack which
when they give the annual operation of
the racetrack at that point they usually
go in with their uh schedule of events
and what dates they want to operate
Certificate of Insurance and then it's
usually approved by the local Comm
Community I understand we heard from the
town that stated that they felt like
they had approximately 8 hours into each
of the different facilities and they
felt as though that was a draw on the
local community from a budgetary
standpoint I took the time to look at
the town of eping as an example where
they do have their two facilities there
and based upon the town of eeping
the the amount of taxes that the two
facilities are are currently licensed in
in that Community are paying they're
paying
$131,000 a year based upon what their
assessments are and what the state uh
listing is on their RSA or on their
Dr from a municipal standpoint they're
paying almost $29,000 a year in taxes to
that Community it's actually 28 946 is
what I come up with they on top of that
they're paying nearly
$98,000 in educational taxes
so when we start talking about how it
affects the local community these these
RAC trcks are actually uh positive to
the local community and I think by
asking them to pay an extra $400 a year
or up to extra $400 a year I just think
is inappropriate because not only are
they not getting anything for their
education piece they understand that
that's part of the process but what
would that additional cost be on the
local community if if they didn't have
those facilities in there
and again when you look through there
are approximately another dozen uh
communities that have racetracks in them
and not one of them was here to speak
out on behalf
of the
increase thank you thank you
representative further comments
discussion seeing
none so the motion the motion before us
is ought to pass on House Bill
346 if you're in favor of the motion
you'll vote Yes if you're opposed to the
motion you'll vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chair
McDonald
yes Vice chair McDonald votes yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative G three votes yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Dolan votes yes representative Elward
yes representative Elward votes yes the
clerk votes
yes representative
France representative France votes yes
representative Kosinski yes
representative Kinski votes yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Murphy votes yes representative Walker
yes representative Walker votes yes
Representative stavis no representative
Davis votes no representative Gilman no
representative Gilman votes no
Representative majori no representative
majority votes no representative frock
no representative frock votes no
representative Colby no representative
Colby votes no repres Representative
gerna no representative gerna votes no
representative Gerard no representative
Gerard votes no Representative grund no
representative grund votes no uh
chairman power
yes chairman power votes yes
the motion of a to pass passes with a
vote of 10 to8 the committee
recommendation on House Bill 346 is
ought to pass and that will go on the
regular
calendar the majority report will be
written by representative Murphy and
correct Minority
Report representative Gerard thank you
and with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill 346
FN next I will open the executive
session on House Bill 165 FN relative to
the maximum amount of disaster relief
funding provided to municipalities after
a natural
disaster um representative France is
recognized for a motion I'd like to make
a motion on HB 165 is ought to pass
thank you is there a second a second
that representative Murphy second that
would you like to speak to your motion
motion representative France
well based on testimony I think the
$25,000 limit is very old outdated it it
really doesn't cover uh any kind of
relief for the municipalities and the
100,000 is just more
reasonable further
discussion representative Gerard thank
you mad chair the other piece that it
actually adds to it as well is the fact
that we're correcting the language so
that way the homeland security
suggestion of making sure this grant
doesn't affect other grants as well
which I think is a very important part
of this bill as well
so further
discussion okay seeing
none so the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 165 if you're in
favor of that motion you'll vote Yes if
you're opposed to the motion you will
vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chair
McDonald
yes Vice chair McDonald vote
Yes representative
Guthrie yes representative Guthrie vote
Yes representative Dolan
yes representative Dolan vote V yes
representative Elward
yes representative Elward votes
yes the clerk votes
yes representative
France representative France votes
yes representative Kosinski
yes representative Kosinski votes
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Murphy vote Yes
representative
Walker
yes representative Walker votes
yes representative stavis
yes representative stavis votes
yes representative Gilman
yes representative Gilman vote
Yes representative majori yes
representative majority votes
yes representative fru
yes representative frock votes
yes representative Colby
yes representative Colby votes yes
representative gerana
yes representative gerna votes yes
representative Gerard yes representative
Gerard votes
yes representative grund yes
representative grund votes yes
chairman power
yes chairman power vote
Yes so the motion passes 18 to zero
without obje uh the committee
recommendation on House Bill 165 is
ought to pass that will go onto the
house consent Cal calendar without
objection and the report will be written
by
representative
France with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill
165 next I will open the executive
session on House Bill 173 relative to
maintaining the purpose of a petitioned
warrant
article the chair recognizes
representative Murphy for a motion I
like to make motion for that ought to
pass is there a second representative K
kazinski seconds that I'll second that
would you like to speak to your motion
representative Murphy yes what they will
do I believe
get rid of the uh problems like the 2C
or to put everything to uh to study it
would be more clear and and precise you
can still change the dollar amount of
the warrant article but you won't be
able to change every single thing inside
it further discussion or
comments representative majori thank you
madam chairwoman and I I find it uh hard
that I might disagree with my friend who
is a moderator but I I will just say
respectfully that I I disagree with the
Au to pass motion and and would favor
itl because I think what's Happening
Here is you're creating a second class
of or a second I guess class is the word
of Warrant articles where now you you
can't change the purpose of these others
can be changed um so I think what you're
doing is is you're creating confusion
here uh for the voters um so I I think
the way the language exist in statute
right now is good and I don't see the
need for this change thank
you additional comments representative
stavis thank you madam chair I also
would support a motion of itl on this
bill mainly because I find the
presumption that any amendment to a
warrant article is uh somehow a
subjugation of the will of the voters
and I think that the word in tent is
extremely vague and could be interpreted
in any number of ways and as I seem to
recall that there was quite a bit of
questioning um on our Republican
colleague side about the fact that it
was confusing and um open to
interpretation thank
you further discussion
so seeing seeing none the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill
173 if you're in favor of the motion
you'll vote Yes if you're opposed then
you'll vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chair
McDonald yes Vice chair McDonald votes
yes representative Guthrie yeah
representative Guthrie votes
yes representative Dolan yes
representative Dolan votes
yes representative Elward
no representative Award votes
no the clerk votes
yes representative
France representative France votes
yes representative kazinski yes
representative kazinski votes
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Murphy votes
yes representative
Walker yes representative Walker votes
yes Representative stavis
no representative stavis votes
no representative Gilman
no representative Gilman votes no
representative majority no
representative majority votes
no representative frock no
representative frock votes
no representative Colby no
representative Colby votes no
Representative gerana no representative
gerana votes
no representative Gerard no
representative Gerard votes no
representative ative grund no
representative grund votes
no chairman power yes chairman power
votes
yes so the vote on that motion is 9 to9
which means that the motion fails
so what what we need to do properly is
we need to
um
explore another motion
correct um the chair recognizes
representative
status thank you madam chair I uh move
itl is there a
second representative frock seconds the
motion of itl
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is inexpedient to Le to to
levitate I think I'm G to
Le I think I'm going to levitate at this
point an expedient to
legislate on House Bill 173 if you're in
favor of that motion you'll vote Yes if
you're opposed on that to to that motion
you'll vote no the clerk will call the
role yes you need a new sheet it's a new
motion hold one second
or
not yeah
actually just
as e
okay I think we're devolving
here okay so um the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 173 and the clerk is ready to
call the
rooll vice chair
McDonald
no representative Guthrie oh no excuse
me uh for clarity Vice chair McDonald
voted no representative
Guthrie representative Guthrie votes
no representative Dolan no
representative Dolan votes
no representative Elward
yes representative Elward votes yes the
clerk votes
no representative France
representative France votes yes
representative Kosinski
no representative kazinski votes
no representative Murphy no
representative Murphy votes no
representative Walker no representative
Walker votes
no representative stavis
yes representative stavis votes yes
representative Gilman yes
representative Gilman votes
yes representative majori yes
representative majori votes yes
representative frock yes representative
frock vote
Yes representative Colby yes
representative Colby votes yes
representative gerana yes representative
Jama votes yes representative Gerard
yes representative Gerard votes yes
representative grund yes representative
grund votes yes chairman power
no chairman power votes no
how is it possible I don't know can't
that doesn't seem right it should be
tied should be
TI she did you change your
vote representative France what was your
vote well I'd like to make a motion to
reconsider no I I'm asking you what your
vote was my vote was yes
okay so I I wasn't clear what you were
saying you want to reconsider your Vote
or the motion the whole
vote okay I I didn't
understand so could you
explain what you want to
do I would like to vote no I was just
confused when I voted I voted yes um I
think it ought to pass so vote no so it
you're voting no on itl because you were
confused on the motion okay
what so the motion itl on House Bill 173
fails with a vote of 9
to9 so
now we need to go to the next possible
motion do I have another motion the
chair recognizes representative McDonald
for a
motion I make a motion to retain Bill HB
173 is there a second I'll second
that representative Murphy seconds
that would you like to speak to your
motion
yes I believe this uh bill needs a
little bit more work and I would suggest
that we uh set up a subcommittee with uh
our colleagues from both both the
Democrats Republicans to work on this
bill so we can uh come up with a
resolution okay the motion before us on
House Bill 173 is retain if you are in
favor of retaining of retaining then you
will vote Yes if you're opposed to the
motion of retain then you will vote
no the clerk will call the
role Vice chair
McDonald yes Vice chair McDonald vote
Yes representative
Guthrie representative Guthrie votes yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Dolan votes
yes representative
Elward yes representative Elward votes
yes the clerk votes
yes representative
France representative France votes
yes representative Kosinski yes
representative karasinski votes
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Murphy votes
yes representative Walker yes
representative Walker votes
yes Representative
stavis
no representative stavis votes
no representative Gilman no
representative Gilman votes
no representative majority no
representative majority votes
no representative frock no
representative frock votes
no representative Colby no
representative Colby votes
no Representative gerana no
representative gerana votes
no representative Gerard no
representative Gerard votes
no Representative grundt no
representative grun votes no chairman
power yes chair and power votes
yes the motion passes with a vote of 10
to8 representative stavis
I have a question so on a retain motion
is that reported on the house calendar
or is that just retained in committee I
believe it's simply retained so there
will be no uh reports that's what I
thought thank
you
okay and with that the executive session
on House Bill 173 is now closed
next I will open the executive session
on House Bill 348 relative to
eligibility for local
assistance the chair recognizes um
representative kazinski madam chair I'd
like to propose an amendment to House
Bill 348 amendment number 2025
d154 thank you is there a
second I'll second that representative
Murphy
seconds the
amendment does everybody have um the
copy of the amendment at their
desk
yes would you like to speak to your um
motion to AC accept amendment
20251 54h to House Bill 348 thank you
madam chair I
would as you see uh on article
two number b or letter
B the criteria for determining
eligibility for general assistance which
may require an individual to provide
proof of residency prior to being
approved for such
assistance acceptable evidence of an
individual's residence may include a
lease car registration utility bill or
any governmen issued document with an
address matching the stated
residents uh previous Bill had a
90day
uh requirement on their time limit thank
you under that section also number one
special consideration may be provided to
non-residents who have left their town
of origin due to domestic violence
stalking sexual assault or human
trafficking I think that answers the
question that we heard in the uh public
hearing subsection two the governing
body May at its discretion authorize the
local assistance administrator to
provide emergency assistance to a
non-resident for up to 72 hours to allow
the applicate to allow application and
communication coordination with the town
of
origin again this answers some of the
concerns raised at our public hearing
about emergency uh
assistance and
then letter
F is being added a monthly local
assistance limit of not less than 50% of
the federal poverty
level if you go back up to Roman numeral
2 the last uh sentence say the guidelin
shall include but not be limited to the
following so F makes sense with a
monthly local assistance limit of not
less than 50% of the federal poverty
level and I think
that would help protect the
taxpayers that in my town of Swansea
we've seen our
uh general assistance budget go from
77,000 three years ago to 224 4,000 last
year and with what's going on in
neighboring states I think this is going
to be an ongoing problem that uh we need
to do something about
now thank you all yield any
questions further discussion on the
amendment um the chair recognizes
representative
frock thank you madam chair
um we heard test testimony on this bill
that the US Supreme Court
had in several cases uh determined that
a residency requirement was not
constitutional yet in your Amendment uh
line seven
and8 it says an an eligibility
requirement may require an individual to
provide provide proof of residency etc
etc does that not open up a town that
may require proof to being uh in
contradiction of the
Constitution and uh decisions of the US
Supreme
Court thank you for the
question representative
um the testimony I heard
brought up the fair protection under the
law or equal protection
and
this residency
requirement
is
basically something that
protects the residents of the
town so
that everybody is being protected by
this amendment
B
protects the taxpayers of the town to
protect
residents and have the funds to be able
to do so Roman numeral or letter one
number one underneath that
protects people that are leaving or
fleeing domestic violence stalking
sexual assault and human
trafficking number
two the governing body May at its
discretion authorize local assistance
administrator to provide emergency
assistance to
non-resident to a non-resident for up to
72 hours again protecting that
person and then F protects the
taxpayers so that they could have funds
available to pay for
this because at the end of the day if
the funds run out no nobody's getting
any protection under the
law
um I would like to offer an
explanation as well before you give your
followup okay so um yes clearly there
was evidence that the residency
requirement of a specific number of days
be it 30 60 90 days in order to receive
welfare
benefits um was deemed to be
unconstitutional by the United States
Supreme Court and the were as you stated
there were a couple of cases that were
brought as evidence of that to this
hearing so that was the concern that the
bill as written because within
May comes the requirement which almost
converts to some municipalities could
make that a shall that you shall um have
residency within this jurisdiction so
that clearly is an
issue
however the the so in order to um
address that
concern that is why we have this
amendment in front of us and if you look
that the the wording of the amendment
now is may require
proof of residency that is different
than
requiring
residency apparently asking for proof of
residency is not
unconstitutional Madam chair I fail to
understand the logic behind requiring
residency and providing proof of
residency they they appear to be one and
the same to my mind I I I would agree
because when I first
um when that was first offered as a
distinction I I myself had to um spend
some time to think deeply about it but
after I I did um look at it carefully
yeah there there there is in fact a a
difference and
that requiring proof of residency is
is constitutional it's it's it's it's
acceptable to to ask for proof of
residency and it says may
require um I would even go so far um as
to say
that there was an individual that
provided testimony here before this
committee uh and I'm pretty I I I
believe he did explain that to to some
degree
yeah
so you may ask a follow-up question of
the
committee um at this point I see no need
to ask a follow-up question uh clearly
we are interpreting the language very
differently so we agree to
disagree further comments representative
Colby thank you madam chair I think um
our M our different interpretations are
exactly what is going to cause a problem
for
municipalities um the question is
getting passed and if this were to be
passed the question of constitutionality
is being passed to the municipality to
kind of hash this out and have the same
discussion we're having uh the amendment
also would create a a huge variation in
requirements from town to
town uh which could result in push
non-residents outside of their
communities uh to those that may offer a
more humanitarian
policy um this is likely to result in
overburdening your surrounding
municipalities uh with the financial
responsibilities of another and that's
just a little bit of food for
thought further comments represent of
Davis and my further comment is that we
fix this problem in the last ter term um
when we addressed uh H uh RSA 165 and we
made it possible for cities like Lebanon
New Hampshire that have New Hampshire's
largest teaching medical facility uh and
many many um resources for people who
are homeless for people who are poor and
needing assistance receiving poor and
needy folks from other towns providing
that assistance we now have the ability
to go back to those towns and seek
recompense for the expenses that we have
laid out for those needy people uh
without ma making them go through
some distinction without a difference
question of proof of residence versus
actual
residents uh and so the fact that we
fixed this in the last term I I fail to
see why it needs to be fixed again
because From lebanon's perspective which
probably expends more on these kinds of
resources than most communities in New
Hampshire we don't have a
problem further
discussion representative
Gilman thank you madam chair uh I'm want
wondering if someone can explain to me a
situation that's happened in my town
where um underage person was uh came out
to their parents and their parents
kicked them out of the house no place to
live just said
bye where in this bill would that person
be taken care of um given that they were
kicked out of
uh uh SAU 16 school so they did not
reside in the town where the school was
they did not reside in they just had in
a residence basically um so where would
that fall within
this representative
kazinski yes I think thank you for the
question I believe right off the top
that
uh number one at line 12 special
consideration may be provided to
non-residents
If the child was not a resident of that
town like you said was kicked out of an
SAU um they would be covered under
this and
also the catchall is number two below
that on line 15
which uh provides emergency assistance
to a non-resident for up to 72 hours to
allow application and communication
coordination with the town of
origin thank
you representative
Colby and I interpreted um thank you
madam chair I interpreted those uh those
two segments that uh that's great uh if
the municipality adopts those two we
wouldn't know if um if
exiter had
adopted
um those
May uh
situations uh so I think the question is
still valid where where would that child
belong where would that minor
go additional
comments representative grundt
thank you madam chair so as much as
we're struggling here trying to define
residency and all the figuring out all
the situations that could possibly
happen we push this down to
municipalities and you're going to get
even more questions and more answers and
more suggestions and it's just going to
I think make it even muddier so I think
we need to make the decision here um if
that decision is appropriate
representative
Murphy the uh I would think that a child
being thrown out of their home by their
parents being a minor child is domestic
violence plain and simple that's my
that's my
thought further
comments represent of Gilman
turn my mic on there we go uh I'm
unclear about the um the very last uh
sentence the f a monthly local
assistance limit of not less than 50% of
the federal poverty
level is that one of the things that the
select board
may decide that there's a
limit thank you madam chair thank thank
you for the
question yeah the
U you look at Roman numeral 2 the local
governing body board of Selectmen in the
case of my town as defined by RSA 6 672
colon 6 of every town and city in the
state shall adopt written guidelines
relative to general assistance the
guidelines shall include but not be
limited to the following so if they
wanted to
have a monthly local assistance limit
they would only be allowed to have it
not less than
50% of the federal poverty level right
now it's
open-ended there is no limit it's just
when the property taxpayers money runs
out okay thank you thank
you further
discussion representative Elward is your
hand up
thank you madam
chairman my question is about
um
item
one regarding special consideration due
to domestic violence stalking
Etc uh do you just show up uh at Town
Hall and say I'm a victim of domestic
violence do you have to somehow prove
that uh does it have to be a police
report
H H how how does that get
determined representative
kazinski thank you madam chairwoman
thank you
representative right now that's how it
happens um they don't have to prove
anything and I wouldn't think they'd
have to
prove
uh
anything in the future they would just
be given special
consideration if they're non-residents
that's left their town of origin due to
those
reasons right now they don't need to
claim any of those reasons they can just
show up and ask for
assistance as a
non-resident follow please yes I is
there any indication of of
fraudulent claims of this type to get
general assistance does that
happen anecdotally I'm a selectman in
town and I can tell you yes but I cannot
discuss it because of the privacy rules
but I can tell you this we are paying
the town of Swansea right now $22,900 a
month to house somebody in nsha in a
hotel room now you might ask yourself
why
Nashua well I'll tell you they showed up
in
town and they ended up going to local
hotels that we paid for they destroyed
the hotels they were kicked out of the
hotels there are 14 hotels around
Swansea that they are no longer allowed
in so they go to
nashaa and it's $2,900 a month that the
taxpayers of my town are paying to house
somebody that doesn't respect the
property
or really the law so we need to do
something thank you so before I um allow
any other um discussion I I just would
want to Simply point out that lines 12
through 14 were added to this amendment
because during the hearing there was
feedback where people expressed the bill
as written they were very concerned that
victims of domestic violence stalking
sexual assault or human trafficking
would be negatively affected by the bill
as written so this um inclusion in the
amendment um is a safety net and a
provision to to to um protect those
people so that they can get in when
they're in those situations and they're
saying that they're victims of of of
these sorts of things they they can get
the help that they need and and not um
and not be um
rejected um so representative
grund uh thank you
um I think we're still required out even
if we have a budget for welfare and more
people come in and exceeds I think we're
still required to pay out I don't think
you can just stop paying out so this
isn't going to stop payouts it's not
going to stop a budget it's not going to
stop much of anything and I feel like
this is really
redefining
welfare rules like who qualifies and
this is Way Beyond what the original
bill was
about representative
stavis if I can remember my train of
thought uh my first question has to do
with uh line
16 uh what happens after the 72 hours
have elapsed
what if somebody shows up at the Town
Hall as you have noted
um and the Town Administrator says well
we have to communicate with your town of
origin to prove who you are and where
you're from but it's Thanksgiving Day
weekend and it's going to be more than
72 hours before anyone can be reached
what happens to that
person and I have a followup m
representative kazinski thank you madam
chairperson um thank you for the
question 72 hours ought to be enough
time to do something four day
weekend you know I think we can get a
hold of somebody or get them in a
shelter within that 72 hours the idea
behind this is
that there's no answer if they can't
prove the residency in that
town and they don't have any of the
other special
considerations their town of origin
should be taken care of them and if that
means that we drive them back to that
town obviously in they're in our town on
Thanksgiving
day and we're supposed to provide care
for 72 hours the town of origin should
be able to do the
same yes representative stavis thank you
for um your answer repres
resentative um it is clear to me that we
are on opposing sides of this issue um
and that's fine that's what we're here
to do I would simply like to say that HB
165 is RSA 165 I'm sorry is uh a statute
that New Hampshire should be rightly
proud of that it demands that we take
care of our needy in this State and it
was passed at a time when you got places
by walking or if you had a horse and it
has been in place since then now there
are cars now there are other modes of
transportation and we have updated the
law to accommodate those changing
circumstances yet we have still remained
true to the principle that we need to
help those Among Us who are the neediest
and I I for one am proud of oursa 165
and do not wish to see it
changed representative
Gerard thank you madam chair um I do
greatly appreciate what you're trying to
do because we've run into the same
concerns I'm looking at this though and
you've talked about how after 72 hours
they're going to have to reach back to
the local community currently the I
believe the bill that was put in last
year after 30 days if they left your
community you were no longer going to be
responsible for how long is this going
to make you responsible for that person
that sitting in nashwa as you keep
describing at this point I I honestly
think it may be a a bigger concern for
your local community as much as I I
can't answer how much is coming across
the border I watched last year as Keen I
know we went over budget and there was
many other communities went in but I
think honestly you're you're creating an
opening to a allow for your community
actually to be responsible for this
person for eternity because they'll
never actually get a a permanent
location if they're living in a
hotel i' like just to quickly add that
um lines 15 through 17 were added due to
um testimony that we
heard that there were concerns that a
person that had just come into town and
they were in an emergency situation and
needed temporary assistance you know if
it's the winter that they could freeze
and this was
um good faith Good Will to to address
those concerns it's it wasn't here to
restrict anything but to alleviate those
concerns further
discussion um
representative rocked
thank you madam chair um I would again
like to point out that in the amendment
lines 12 through
14 dealing with people who
are are or claimed to be victims of
domestic violence so
stalking sexual assault or human
trafficking it's a May it's not a shall
so when a town writes their required
guidelines they could very possibly say
that people who are V who
are victims of domestic violence etc etc
can go to the next
town we're not going to take care of
them representative
Colby thank you madam chair um along the
same lines it also continues special
consideration may be provided to
non-residents the governing body May at
its discretion authorize the local
assistance so again it this is going to
cause so many variations and so many
situations from municipality to
municipality being different thank you
so yes I I would like to um add because
I have heard that comment about the peac
meil or Patchwork application of that um
to be clear
we already have that because the
guidelines um shall include but not be
limited to so these are
minimum guidelines but
municipalities may include other
guidelines so inherently in the bill I
mean in the statute without this bill we
already have that you know differences
between municipalities based on my
understanding of the
law so to me this is not making it's
it's more of the same but it just gives
it gives options it gives local control
with regards to what that particular
munici M
municipality wants how they want to
administer their um their
aid Representatives oh
yes so um I'm just looking at the clock
and I'm not trying to rush anything um
but with regards to this amendment here
before us I think we've debated it and
discussed it sufficiently I feel that we
should um move to vote on the acceptance
of this amendment or not is
representative stavis are you in in
agreement with that to move forward
complete agreement thank you thank
you so the motion before us right now is
to accept
Amendment
225-5418 if you are in favor of the
amendment you will vote Yes if you are
opposed to the amendment you will vote
no the clerk will call the role
Vice chairman
McDonald yes Vice chairman McDonald
votes yes representative Guri
no representative Guthrie votes no
representative Dolan yes representative
Dolan votes yes representative
Elward yes representative Elward votes
yes the clerk votes
yes representative France
representative France votes yes
representative karasinski yes
representative karasinski votes yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Murphy votes yes representative Walker
yes representative Walker votes yes
Representative stavis no representative
stavis votes no representative Gilman no
representative Gilman votes no
representative majority no
representative majority votes no
representative frock no representative
frock votes no representative Colby no
representative Colby votes no
Representative gerana no representative
gerana votes no representative Gerard no
representative Gerard votes no
Representative grund no representative
grund votes no chairman power yes
chairman power votes yes
N9 to nine the vote to accept Amendment
d01 is it
54h um fails on a vote
9-9 the chair recognizes representative
McDonald uh Madam chairperson I'd like
to recommend uh retaining on this bill
is there a second
representative Kosinski seconds that
motion would you like to speak to the
motion I think we've discuss the uh the
bill enough so
far is there any um discussion on that
okay
okay so the motion before us is to
retain House Bill 348 if you are in
favor of retaining the bill you will
vote Yes if you are opposed to retaining
the bill you will vote no the clerk will
call the
role Vice chairman McDonald yes Vice
chairman McDonald votes yes
representative
Guthrie representative Guthrie votes yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Dolan vote Yes representative Elward yes
representative Elward vote Yes the clerk
votes yes representative
France representative France votes yes
representative kazinski yes
representative kazinski votes yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Murphy votes yes representative Walker
yes representative Walker vote Yes
representative stavis yes representative
stavis votes yes representative Gilman
yes representative Gilman votes yes
representative majority no
representative majority votes no
representative frock vote no
representative frock votes no
representative Colby no representative
Colby votes no representative gerana
yes representative gerana votes yes
representative Gerard yes representative
Gerard votes yes representative grund
yes representative grun votes yes
chairman power yes chairman power vote
Yes the motion to retain house bill when
are we on
348 um passes with a vote of 15-3
and with that I will close the executive
session on House Bill
348 do we have to know right
now no he's he's helping they they need
to know right now we
I don't I don't believe so yeah that's
not my plan okay so we're being asked if
we're going to extend beyond five and my
prediction is
No
so at this time I will open the
executive session on House Bill
453 prohibiting municipalities from
Banning you of Grounds Maintenance and
snow and ice removal equipment with
internal combustion
engines make motion the clerk the
clerk the chair recognizes
representative Bella
Burke I would like to make the motion on
HB 453 which is prohibiting
municipalities from Banning use of
ground maintenance and snow and ice
removal equipment with internal
combustion engines I would like to make
a motion all to
pass there a
second representative Elward seconds
would you like to speak to your
motion upon reading further into the
bill the sponsor felt it necessary to
draw up and draft this legislation um to
be voted on uh and if you notice you've
go to page two it goes into individual
citizens actually being able to use uh
gas
combustible type snow removal and such
and as I live off the
grid I can tell you that just relying
strictly on electricity is very very
expensive and because I do represent
farmers in a rural
District this is why I wish to at least
have this Safeguard in place so we we
could do one or the other but not be
prohibited from one
further comments discussion
representative
Dolan thank you madam chair I I think
it's
uh I think it's uh unwise of us to uh
require uh such Behavior as this would
require municipalities especially to
recapitalize a very expensive uh
equipment
and drive the cost of local government
much higher than it already
is for other discussion representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman um we
have a a precedent a precedent no rules
the precedent if the sponsor doesn't
show up we've gone it all on the bill
we're not able to ask questions we're
not able to get clarity um regardless of
what has been submitted we haven't been
able to uh to go through the normal
process
uh with this bill and in keeping with
that precedent that we have of going itl
uh I can't support the O OTP
motion further discussion representative
Guthrie thank you madam chair I agree
with the previous uh two speakers and it
seems to me that uh Lo any local
community that wants to Institute this
at a local level don't need the state to
tell them they can do it
further
comments so I had two quick comments so
the first one would be with regards to
the Precedence of this this um committee
we we do have a new
chair and um new membership and while in
general I agree with with that precedent
the chair is privy to um information
that it was through no fault of the the
the individual the prime sponsor so
therefore in in l of his presence he he
did send written testimony to us and the
bill is um in my opinion straightforward
and and quite understandable and so my
second um comment would be that the bill
clearly Pro protects individual property
owners and businesses from restrictive
and overreaching Municipal regulations
so I uh am in support of this
bill additional discussion
seeing none the motion before us is
ought to pass on House Bill
453 if you are in favor of the motion
you will vote Yes if you are opposed to
the motion you will vote no the clerk
will call the
role Vice chair
McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie is it
a question
Mr yes um representative gri you
confused ought to pass yes the motion
before us is ought to pass thank you and
what is your vote
no representative
Dolan
yes representative Elward
yes the clerk says
yes representative
France representative kazinski
yes representative Murphy
yes excuse me representative Walker
yes Representative stavis
no representative Gilman no
Representative magor no representative
frock
no representative Colby
no Representative gerana
no repres representative Gerard no
Representative grund
no forgot
me chairman power
yes so the mo the motion fails with a
vote of 9 to9 do I have another motion
representative stavis is recognized for
a motion
thank you madam chair I move itl on HB
453 is there a
second second representative Colby
seconds the
motion discussion representative MC
McDonald I hope me understand this right
but if
we if this becomes a law it's going to
let the towns tell us that we can't buy
gas powerered lawnmowers weed whackers
or anything gas powered to do our lawn
do I have a correct interpretation of
that that would be correct so that would
mean the town would tell me that I would
have to buy electric operated tools that
run on batteries instead of using my gas
powerered chainsaw riding lawnmower push
mower or anything powered by gas to take
care of my lawn is that correct that
would be correct thank
you additionally um to piggy back on off
of what the vice chairman just stated
this would also if this if if this bill
were not to pass then municipalities
could could restrict even contractors
landscapers from from using such
equipment within the the bounds of the
municipality representative Elward I
have a
question yes um would this include
tractors and ATVs with snow blades for
clearing private uh
roads further
discussion representative majori I think
the very fact that we're asking question
underscores the point that I made we
weren't able to ask the sponsor we are
making conclusions but I would like to
hear from the sponsors of these bills
the answers to these
questions thank
you further discussion
representative
Murphy Madam chair is it out of order to
ask for a um another motion while this
one's still on the floor I'd like to
have I'd like to maybe
retain well the individual that offered
the motion could withdraw the motion if
they so
choose further
discussion seeing
none the motion before us is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
453 if you're in favor of that motion
you'll vote Yes if you're opposed you
will vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chair
McDonald
no represent Presa Guthrie
yes representative Dolan
no representative Elward
no the clerk says
no representative France
no Representative kazinski
no representative Murphy
no representative Walker
no representative stavis
yes representative Gilman yes
representative representative majori yes
representative frock yes representative
kby yes representative gerana yes
representative Gerard yes representative
grundt
yes chairman power no
the motion of itl fails with a vote of 9
to9 do I have another
motion I like to make a motion to retain
is there a second second representative
Walker
seconds just would you like to speak to
your
motion I think it is a I think the
whatever we can maybe get the uh the
sponsor the main sponsor here to talk
about it at some later point to satisfy
our friends across the
aisle further comments or
discussion seeing none the motion before
us is to retain House Bill 453 if you're
in favor of retaining you will vote Yes
if you are opposed to retaining you will
vote no the clerk will call the
role Vice chairman McDonald
yes representative
Guthrie representative Dolan yes
representative Elward yes the clerk says
yes representative
France representative representative
karasinski yes representative Murphy yes
representative Walker yes Representative
stavis
no representative Gilman no
representative majori no representative
frock no representative Colby no
Representative gerana no representative
Gerard
yes representative grunt
yes chairman power yes
the motion to retain House Bill 453
passes with a vote of
12-6 and with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill
no next I will open the executive
session on House Bill 488 relative to
limiting conflicts of interest for
municipal board and committee
members the chair recognizes
representative Dolan for a motion thank
you madam chair I'd like to make a
motion to
retain House Bill 488 this is a bill oh
just hold please do I have a
second a second that um representative
Elward seconded that first thank you
though discussion uh uh excuse me
representative Dolan would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank you the
uh this is a bill that had no sponsor
before us and that we couldn't discuss
it and when we did get into it it would
became evident right away that at least
one perhaps more than one amendment was
going to be needed to to bring this uh
Bill forward so we I at this point we
should just admit that and go right on
to the retain
make that motion by
acclamation have the chair get
one further any discussion on this I'll
second
that okay so I don't see any discussion
on this so um the motion before us is to
retain House Bill 488 if you're in favor
of retaining the bill you will vote Yes
if you are opposed to retaining the bill
you will vote no the clerk will call the
role
Vice chair
McDonald
yes Vice chair McDonald votes yes
representative
Guthrie representative Guthrie vote Yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Dolan votes yes representative Elward
yes representative Elward votes yes the
clerk votes yes representative
France representative France votes yes
representative Kosinski yes
representative Kosinski vote Yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Murphy vote Yes representative
Walker yes representative Walker vote
Yes representative stavis yes
representative stavis votes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Gilman votes yes represent
representative majority yes
representative majori vote Yes
representative frock yes representative
frock vote yes representative Colby yes
representative Colby vote Yes
representative german yes representative
ger votes yes representative Gerard yes
representative Gerard votes yes
representative grund yes representative
grun vote Yes chairman power yes
chairman power vote
Yes the motion to retain House Bill 488
passes with a vote of 18 to
Zer so with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill
488 so that concludes our publicly
notice business for today but before we
adjourn I have a few afternoon
announcements so very quickly the week
of February 2nd we will have hearings
scheduled and we will be meeting on
Tuesday February 4th not in this room
but in room
307 I um believe that there's a house
session planned for Thursday February 6
we should see that in the calendar when
that is published tonight or tomorrow
the week of febru February 9th plan to
meet on Monday February 10th for
hearings and executive session our
committee has 60 house bills referred to
it with a few that um I was able to be
vacated so the weekend your chair spent
over six hours planning out going
through every Bill and planning out a
massive Master committee schedule so
based on that road map um the committee
will in fact need to meet during the
last week in February in order to meet
house deadlines so I am looking at
Tuesday February 25th for hearings only
that being said if um if you want to
pick up another day and and meet um
three or four times in a week um let me
know and I could um change my master
plan and quickly I'd like to thank
everybody who authored committee reports
last week thanks to your quick
turnaround in your excellent work first
time out the out of the gate I was able
to submit all of those eight reports to
the committee assistant on Sunday so
that when she came in on Monday all
those reports were in in her inbox so
that she could process them I'm sure she
appreciates your hard work and um for
those who are writing committee reports
please have them into me um within 48
hours if there's something uh an
exception something comes up please
reach out to me and I can work with you
um at this point uh the meeting is now
adjourned